(upbeat music)
Alrighty, after an extended series of format deviations,
which were met with,
let's just say a diversity of reactions.
Today Roll On Original, "Original" returns
featuring my favorite and let's face it,
the audience favorite scuba masked,
Paul to my John, Cale to my Reed
jokes, which will soon be understood,
Sir, Adam Skolnick.
How are you doing buddy?
You know Rich, I'm not gonna bore you with my problems.
All right, let me just interrupt you right then and there.
Because I will not allow you to bore me with your problems.
Do I have a blister under my toenail?
Yes, I do.
Okay, good, anything else?
Get it all out.
No, I have no problems really to speak of.
Not in the grand scheme of things,
but busy times getting ready to go away.
We're getting the first passport stamp
in Zuma's booklet.
You going down south?
Going down south baby.
Things are changing rapidly with the new variant, however.
I know.
Travel restrictions are starting to abound.
They are.
But Mexico has recently announced...
You know when you're getting a flight to anywhere now,
they say check on the latest whatevers.
And so the new guidelines.
So we click on the guideline and I'm expecting,
you have to get a test or proof of vaccination or whatever.
And it says, Mexico has no requirements.
(Adam and Rich laughing)
Come on in everybody.
Mexico has no requirements.
But I'm hopeful that the Omicron variant
actually makes it counterintuitively safer in a way.
People can cancel their plans.
There's not as many people at the airport.
And we're going to a part of the world
where they're getting 43 cases a day
over the last seven days
in a 500 mile region.
So we're actually going to a safer place.
I don't think that it's gonna chill holiday travel.
I think people are like, "Okay, another variant.
And we've been doing this for two years.
We have to live our life."
Setting aside government imposed restrictions.
I don't know how much of an impact that's gonna have
on people canceling plans that they've made.
Maybe not.
And are looking forward to it, but we'll see.
Okay, well, before we get into it,
just for those who might be new or newer.
Roll On is our inconsistently bi-weekly news entertainment,
AMA mashup, where we loosen the metaphorical ties of it.
Discuss matters of import, intrigue and nonsense.
Answer listener questions,
have a few laughs, hopefully have a bit of fun.
And we got lots to cover today.
We don't really have a big story.
We just have lots of stories.
We'll see how long it's gonna take us to get through.
But I'm excited about today's show,
before we dive into it though,
I do wanna mention that SriMu Julie's
amazing, plant-based cheese offerings.
They're in the midst of getting everything ready
for the holidays.
So if that's on your wishlist for the holidays,
if that's a gift that you wanna give
or something that you wanna enjoy yourself,
you have to get your order in by December 13th.
To do that, go to SriMu.com.
S-R-I-M-U .com
And if you use code RRP 22, you get 22% off.
Just wanted to slide that in right there.
There's no better plant-based cheese company
that I've ever tasted and the people and the staff,
just like your staff here.
Just top quality people.
I had a good fortunate to be able to meet
a couple of them and just incredible operation
and a big fan.
Big SriMu fan.
Good people, good product, all of that.
Where do we wanna begin?
Anything else you wanna mention before I check in?
No, it's great to be back.
I appreciate the love on the onlines for the OJ Roll On.
I even got one yesterday saying,
"Where's the regular Roll On?"
We diverted from our format so many times
that I can't remember the last time it was just you and me.
It was super fun to have Brogan here.
And he adds a certain flare and spice to the program.
But I have to say, Adam,
you have a hardcore fan base out there,
that are very vocal about making sure
that you are in good...
They wanna hear from Skolnick.
They don't wanna bunch of other noise.
They just wanna hear it directly from you.
You know what, and I love them for it.
I love you.
Hardcore fan base.
I love them too.
I'm getting ready to go to Austin.
We're recording this on what's the date?
The 29th of November.
Usually we record these on Monday
and then we put them up Thursday,
but we're recording this the Monday in advance
because were gonna be out of town in Austin
at the running event.
Which is kind of a trade show for the running industry.
I'm doing that for Solomon.
So I'm gonna to be there the whole week of December one.
So we're, front-loading this a little bit.
But I did wanna catch up a little bit on things
that have been going on.
We had a low key Thanksgiving.
Julie was actually in Egypt.
She just got back.
She was on a spiritual pilgrimage there.
It sounds like it was an incredible trip.
Maybe I'll have her back on to share.
She went on an insane walk about which was cool.
By herself?
No, she was with a group of people.
But they were in Cairo and did all the pyramids
and went down to Luxor and they were on a boat
in the Nile for five days.
She saw so much cool stuff.
But last week I was in Vancouver
participating in the Planted Expo.
Which was a really cool kind of plant-based nutrition event
that was put on by Stevan Mirkovic.
He's like the main guy there, which was really cool.
I got to give a talk,
and I also got to do a live podcast event in a church,
which was really cool.
For a smaller audience, like maybe,
I don't know how many people were there,
200 people or something like that.
With these guys, Zach Berman and Dean Morris
who have a podcast called A Little More Good.
This is their T-shirt.
I'm rocking their T-shirt.
Nice.
In my seerucker suit.
I love the suit.
It was really fun.
They haven't put that out yet.
I don't know when it's going up, but I'll let you guys know.
But we had a great talk.
And it was just nice to be amongst people
and to do a live event.
Zack is a co-founder of this company called Juice Truck,
which was Canada's first cold pressed juice bar.
He founded that in 2011, I think.
And then Dean is this sort of iconoclast pastor.
He's a pastor, but he's a vegan and he's a runner
and he's like a Lululemon ambassador.
And we had a really good time.
I shared a couple of pictures from that.
Cool.
Did the Planted Expo do a ritual crossword
because someone-
Oh yeah, yeah, yeah.
So that was for the live podcast event.
I didn't end up even seeing it.
And they said they would send it to me,
but they did a whole crossword puzzle based on words
that I have a tendency to pull out of my quiver.
They asked me for a few additions.
I think that those made it.
They mentioned that they had spoken to you.
And those found their way into the thing.
And then I guess they were handing them out
in printed form or whatever.
And some people were like, "Oh cool."
And others were like, "What, I have homework."
What do you want me to do with this?
They didn't understand.
Anyway, I should get my hands on that.
We gotta put it up on the site, people would love this.
I know, I know.
I got to get...
All right guys, I'm sure you're listening to this.
Send me that thing.
Also I wanted to thank everybody who submitted
a listener story.
We put the call out over the last couple of weeks
to call our voicemail and leave a message
with how the show has impacted you.
I think we've received something like 200.
How many did we get guys?
Almost, yeah.
Close to 200 stories amongst them,
some pretty incredible ones.
And we're in the process of editing that together
for a really cool end of year episode.
That we're putting together.
So thank you for everybody who did that.
It's gonna be pretty special.
Don't we want them to be credible though Rich.
Not incredible.
Are we gonna fact check.
Well, you're the journalist here.
You wanna fact check them.
And get on the phone with all these people and verify
the veracity of these stories.
I'm pointing out the term incredible.
Because incredible means amazing, but it could also mean,
it's also there's that other usage,
which we don't really use anymore.
We use it incorrectly.
99.9% of the time I suspect.
Yeah, myself included.
I'm gonna check myself on that.
Now we use superlative.
That's one of yours.
Well, that gets misused also.
Superlatives in general, get misused.
Are we gonna go down the grammar rabbit hole?
Sorry.
Have you been...
(indistinct chatter)
I miss you Rich, I miss you.
Ever since I shared that guy on TikTok,
who does the grammar stuff about biweekly.
I started following him and he's
just a constant source of enjoyment.
For the videos that he creates.
I forget his name.
We'll link it up.
You have to be on TikTok to follow him or?
No, he posts them on Instagram as well.
I gotta follow him.
Yeah, they're pretty good.
Send me that guy again, please.
We have a couple people that we'd like to remember.
You wanna kick this off?
Yeah, in memoriam, memoriam.
In memoriam.
In memoriam, in memorial.
Two Intrepid souls lost.
my friend, Tom Stoddard.
This is his latest book.
He's a photo journalist who I worked with in the past.
He's covered the civil war in Lebanon,
the siege of Sarajevo, the fall of the Berlin Wall,
the 2003 invasion of Iraq,
as well as the original Gulf war under the first Bush.
Basically covered conflicts,
catastrophe socialists around the world for 40 years.
But that doesn't even come into completely
paint the picture of who he was.
he was so well-regarded Tony Blair had him as a...
Had him along with him for a week.
Just him in the entire day-
Photographing?
Yeah, photograph from the entire day.
He only shot in black and white for a long time.
He only use Leicas.
He used to quote Canadian photographer, Ted Grant.
"If you photograph in color,
you see the color of their clothes.
But if you photograph in black and white,
you see the color of their soul."
Just a great guy from Northern England who knocked
on the door of his local paper and begged for a job.
They made him an assistant photographer
and basically never turned back.
That was in the 70s.
And I met him because in 2007,
I did a story for men's health.
A feature on these doctors and healthcare workers,
both American and Korean
in this ethnic provinces of Burma.
But they were...
A lot of them were expatriated into Thailand
and their base of operations was in Mesa, Thailand.
And Tom was the photographer that came with me
on this feature,
as I followed them into displaced people's camps.
Or we did together to displace people's camps.
And these were villagers, who've been...
Had their villages torched
and were runoff their ancestral homeland.
And we're trying to flee to the safety of Thailand,
but had to live in these penned areas on the river,
in these camps.
And aid workers were kind of giving them food and medicine.
And that was the story of current state,
much of current state for years.
And Tom and I snuck over the border.
We went to this camp.
People who just had their homes burned down
and spent a week together.
First in Bangkok then Mesa, then Karen State.
And at that time 2007,
I was still kind of,
wondering if this was gonna work as a job.
I started in 2000 was writing grants
and doing what I had to do.
2004, I started getting bigger publications.
We started LA Yoga and all of that.
But by 2007,
I was still very much in the Eviction Notice phase,
just starting with Lonely Planet.
So things are just starting to get better.
And Tom he would remind me,
"We are lions mate.
We are lions."
Just remind me that we have to remain confident.
We may have to remain optimistic.
We have to be able to fight through all the adversity
that comes with trying to do this job in a climate
that is not conducive to that.
Because if you're getting paid months after the expenses
come through, nobody cares.
Your bills are still due.
And then you have to deal with editors
that are kind of fickle.
They can be fickle.
They can kill a story.
They can mess with a story.
Not that I have that problem with editors in general.
But it does happen.
And Tom used to refer to him lovingly as the desk fuckwits.
And not that he thought that of those of the editors
that he worked with, but just that,
it's a way of thinking so that you can maintain
some sort of sanity while you go and do this.
And meanwhile you're photographing
or interviewing people who've been through hell.
Most recently his biggest story was the migration
of people from Syria.
And into, I think it was Lesbos into Greece,
that massive influx.
He was there for that.
To see him shoot, he's rolling on the ground.
He's got knee pads, he's got elbow pads.
I mean, he's a full body experience.
This is into his 60's, doing this.
And then he had a show
at the Annenberg Space for photography in Century City.
That's the last time I saw him.
And I didn't even know he was sick.
He kind of kept that under wraps.
How did he perish?
He had cancer.
And he just didn't tell anybody really.
I guess it's really close, close friends knew,
his wife knew.
He was the type of guy.
He married the love of his life.
It turned out to be,
but it was his best friend's wife and he died,
the best friend died.
And then he ends up marrying.
A very Conrad Anker in a way.
Same with Julie's dad.
Actually is a similar thing.
And she's now had to bury both of those guys.
And so the memorial, I think is today,
or it's this week.
This is most reasonable.
Like I said, Extraordinary Women.
It's some amazing photographs.
The guy's truly a legend in the business,
and a great, great mentor to me and a great soul.
And I miss him and I love him.
And I just wanted to share who he was with you guys.
Sorry for your loss.
How long ago was that the exhibit was going on?
That was 2016.
Oh, so it was five years ago.
But I spoke with him.
We communicated in 2020,
right before Zuma was born.
Yeah, when this book came out.
Life is short man.
On that subject, I've got a Memorial to share as well.
My friend, Jason Plummer passed away this last week.
Too soon.
I'm not quite sure that there's clarity
on how he passed away.
It was either an aneurysm or a heart attack.
I think he was on a stationary bike at the time.
Jason was a teammate of mine at Stanford
an exceptionally talented swimmer.
Commonwealth games champion.
Distance freestyler from Brisbane.
He was on the 88 Australian Olympic team.
He was world surf race champion.
This guy was very talented,
but he was also kind of a wild man.
He was a free spirit.
He was the class clown.
He was, I think it's fair to say, not keen on authority.
He was kind of a good time Charlie.
And was always the life of the party.
And I had plenty of good times with him.
He had this history of clashing with Skip Kenny, our coach,
who was a Marine sniper and liked to run the team.
Like it was a military outfit.
Which Skip is a very complicated person
and has a very complicated legacy.
He was a guy who put team above all.
And I learned a lot about how you build teams
and how you create cohesion amidst...
Amongst individuals for a greater purpose.
But he also kind of rained on this idea of fear,
which didn't really work for me.
And he was a guy who, if you were a favorite of his,
it worked really well.
But if you were kind of on the outs or somebody
that he didn't quite get along with, it was a bumpy road.
And Jason was certainly one of those people.
And there was this huge scandal in 2007 where it came out
that Skip had expunged swimmers that he didn't like
from the Stanford record books.
Like he literally...
He had beef with certain people.
And so in the media guide, he just like...
They compiled these lists of like top 10 times
for each event.
He just line item, removed them from the record books.
And I think Jason might've been the one just to see it
and realize it.
And he made a stink about it.
Because he was one of the people
who had earned a spot on these lists.
And he had been surreptitiously removed.
Without any explanation.
It's like something out of a Wes Anderson movie.
(Adam laughs)
It's sort of an ego is the enemy.
Skip had a beef, his ego got caught up in it
and he made an error and he ended up getting suspended.
And ultimately that was the end of his career.
And that career was an incredibly successful one.
He lorded over, perhaps one of the most successful
collegiate swim programs
in the history of collegiate swimming.
I mean, he won 26 consecutive (indistinct) Championships.
And he was...
You know, like I had my ups and downs with him.
I have friends that were on the outs with him
and I have friends that loved him.
And my relationship with him is fine.
But he's a crusty, difficult human being.
Plummer has this quote where...
I found it in an article, getting ready for today.
Where he said in reference to Skip
that he was a guy with an ax to grind
who has circumvented common decency.
And I think you can understand why he would feel that way.
But at the same time,
Skip would create these kind of traditions amongst the team
that really congealed us as a unit.
One of those things was called The Pants.
There was this pair of old sweat pants that dated back,
I don't know when.
Like they almost felt like sandpaper.
They were so old, these red sweat pants.
And each year the team would vote on
who would earn the right to wear those pants for the year.
And it was basically the person
who had the most enthusiastic team spirit.
And you would kind of have to wear them, not every day,
but most days.
To meets and stuff?
No, every day,
Every day.
You just wear them for like an entire year.
Oh yeah, here, I found the note.
The pants were from 1967.
From the 1967 (indistinct) Championship
My friend Sam McAdam had them one year,
Mike Reynolds had them one year
and then I had them one year.
You did?
I got to wear the pants for a year.
That's awesome.
But it was stuff like that,
that was sort of created by Skip.
These beautiful little things.
And there was all kinds of other traditions
when we do this annual road trip and all that kind of stuff.
But Skip's tenure ended in
this sort of cloud of ill repute that had no small part
due to Jason and what had gone down.
But all of this to say that Jason will be missed.
he really was like a larger than life character.
And he's gone too soon.
Where was he living?
Was he local here?
In Dallas?
I think he was doing high-end real estate there
or something like that,
but had that kind of Aussi spirit.
Where he would light up a room when you would walk into it.
Sorry about that one.
Here's to the here's to Stoddard and Plummer.
Yeah here's to those guys.
But on the subject of talented athletes,
do we wanna talk about the ascent of the Norwegians?
We must, they've announced themselves.
I don't know if they have been announced.
It's the age of the Norwegians
on the triathlon/Ironman landscape these days.
You know, I would let Norwegians
just run the world personally.
Having met some Norwegians
and seeing how they run their country.
I'm open to-
They make a very nice safe car.
Yeah, I think I'm open to the Norwegians-
Wait, is Volvo Norwegian?
No, it's Swedish?
Yeah.
No Swedish.
That's a faux pas.
No, that's a faux pas
Yeah, I'm sorry.
Norway, it doesn't make automobiles.
That's what I mean.
They're above the fray.
Well, let's get specific.
You wanna talk about Kristian first?
Kristian Blummenfelt and Gustav Iden.
Kristian, the Olympic champ that no one expected
was in his first ever Ironman.
I know the first iron man he's ever done.
he's ever entered in Cozumel.
And he rocked it in a world record time
of seven hours and 21 minutes.
It's not officially a world record yet because the swim,
which he completed in 39 minutes for 2.4 mile swim,
which is bonkers, was current aided.
And I think they actually measured it
and it came up like 500 meters short or something like.
So it's unlikely this will ever be considered.
(indistinct) wrote an article for Triathlete.
And said whether or not it will be considered
a world record.
It almost doesn't matter.
I mean, he was like six minutes faster
than the previously,
you know, fastest recorded time, which was (indistinct).
I think it was (indistinct).
Who gave him major props online,
on the socials.
But the bike is four hours into minutes amazing.
But the run is what blew me away.
2:35 marathon.
It's crazy.
It's crazy, right?
Yeah.
Also not for nothing,
being like really hot and humid, it's unbelievable.
It's unbelievable.
He thinks that he could have run much faster.
That's incredible to me.
I know.
It's amazing, his first ever Ironman.
There's some weirdness around this.
Brad Culp had done some reporting on this as well.
That the Ironman organization made
no reference to this for days.
They were covering a different Ironman race
that was going on at the same time as Ironman Cozumel.
Later on, they ended up tweeting some stuff,
but I found it to be very strange.
I don't know what that is about.
Do you think it has to do
with the race organizers and Cozumel?
Do you think it has to do with
(indistinct chatter)
I don't know somebody...
I tweeted this out.
How come like no love from the Ironman organization
for Kristian's performance.
Or even more broadly,
anything about I am Cozumel to begin with.
And somebody said something about how
the Ironman organization had like licensed the name
of the Cozumel but it wasn't...
It's not part of like the hardcore family of Ironman race.
I don't know if that's true or not.
But I don't know why that would color whether or not
they would report on it when it is an official Ironman race.
I'm gonna get into it
because I'm doing a story on Kristian for
New York Time Sports.
It will come out in late December.
It's obviously inspired by this incredible performance,
and I got the idea because you messaged me about it.
And I'm like, "Oh, that is a good story."
Well, I had the opportunity to meet him.
I met him at an event in Century City
that was like a day or two before the Malibu triathlon
and got to chat with him a little bit.
And then I saw him at the race
because I was doing those celebrity relay
and he was doing a celebrity relay.
So even though he went 7:21,
let's be clear that my relay
with Alexi Pappas and Mary Cain beat his relay.
Alexi, remind me of that.
But he's such a sweet, sort of soft-spoken,
Uber talents of a guy.
He's very humble and grounded.
I interviewed him before and he was really cool
and accessible and I'm really looking forward to this
and he's racing again in Jacksonville,
I believe, December 5th
But the key races for him are St. George in May
and then Kona in October.
And he's also part of this sub seven project.
You know about this?
Yeah, I've heard of it.
Yeah, I think Talbot Cox told us a little bit about it
when we were together in Utah.
Akin to the breaking two project
where they created a scenario conducive to Kipchoge
breaking two hours in the marathon.
They're doing something similar in Ironman
where Christian and Alister Brownlee are gonna go
for a sub seven Ironman.
And then Lucy, Charles Barkley and Nicola Spiric
are gonna go for a sub eight.
And they throw the rule book out.
Much like how Kipchoge did it on that track.
And he had Pacers and wind blockers and all of that,
they're gonna do something similar in Ironman.
Peloton and pacers.
Yeah, pacers, peloton.
And I read an article where Christian was talking about
how that's gonna work and how he wants to use,
take advantage of those tools.
And for the run he wants his high school buddy,
Gustav Iden, or Eden.
I'm not sure how you pronounce it,
to pace him on the run.
Now Gustav fellow Norwegian.
These guys went to high school together.
It's incredible.
Just went 234 in his Ironman debut,
which is unbelievable.
On the run.
No, oh, I'm sorry.
He went 734 I believe.
Okay, unbelievable.
Sorry I misspoke.
But Gustav is a better runner than Kristian.
And Kristian said something in this article to the tune of
Well, Gustav can get up and run a 220,
any day of the week.
Like it's no big deal.
So to have Gustav pace him on the marathon,
Kristian thinks that he can go to 220, 225
or something like that, which is just unbelievable.
Well, they do a pool swim to make sure
that they don't like too many...
Do a longer distance?
Probably not no.
I doubt it it'll be in a pool,
but the details of this,
like the date and the venue and all of that
is to be determined.
Like they haven't even figured out or they haven't announced
what the course would be.
But he'll get to have all of these athletes
will get to have Pacers on the bike.
If you could draft on the bike.
That's a huge thing.
Well it's like what we saw with James.
So can Kristian drop 21 minutes off his Ironman time
with those extra advantages, we'll find out,
but it's cool that they're doing it.
And it makes it exciting.
Well, it's gotta come off.
I mean, if he thinks he can shave off the run,
which he says he can,
so if he can shave 5 minutes off the run and 15 minutes
off the bike.
I would think he could get with...
I dunno if you can do a whole Peloton.
I don't know how they're structuring it.
But if he can just be in a pack on the bike.
Or is it gonna be a criterion or is it?
I don't know.
I don't know, I guess we'll find out.
Yeah, but the point being these Norwegian guys,
and there's a third guy as well,
are crushing it at the moment and it's cool
to watch it unfold.
It is cool.
Yeah, all right.
Well, why don't we take a quick break
and we'll be back with lots more.
(upbeat music)
All right, and we're back.
Should we talk about
Kyle Rittenhouse and Ahmaud Arbery?
I feel like we should,
even though on the date that this comes out,
there's been a million takes on this.
It's sort of been in the news cycle
and we're at the risk of it
not being in the news cycle anymore.
Maybe people are tired of hearing about it.
But I feel like because social justice is an important theme
or subject of the Roll On and the podcast
in general that we should at least spend
a couple of minutes on this.
Yeah, I mean, I think that's how Roll On kind of started
it launched with talking about these,
wrestling with these issues.
And I think people wanna hear your take on it,
especially as someone who was a lawyer,
you're gonna have a viewpoint on these two cases
and that kind of the nuances involved.
Well, what is your take on the Rittenhouse acquittal?
Let's start there.
It didn't surprise me.
I was not surprised by the acquittal.
I'm not surprised by it, but it does bother me
that someone who is a juvenile
who obviously has some sort of emotional problems.
Had someone buy him a gun and came from out of state
to defend businesses,
even though no one really invited him to do it,
he wasn't really connected to these businesses
and then comes with a gun and then everything happens.
And then even after that,
the police kind of let him walk by with a gun,
which shows you there was a lot of misreporting,
especially during the trial.
People thinking that he killed black people,
that's not what happened.
But it doesn't matter who he killed.
But that was the assumption that I saw on social media.
But I think it is fair to say if he was black
and he'd come there and shot two people,
there's no way the cops would let them just walk by them
with a loaded weapon.
So, I mean, you could argue with me,
but I mean, I find that very hard to believe.
So that's a problem.
The idea of vigilantism in general is a problem.
But it looked to me...
And it didn't watch the whole thing,
but it looked to me that the prosecution was over-matched
that the law wasn't necessarily on their side
and that he made a credible case for self-defense
and he was emotionally stunted.
And so when I think of it,
I think of it as a great tragedy for all involved,
including him.
He probably doesn't see it that way himself at the moment.
Cause he's getting a lot of love from people
who are using him as a pawn.
And they're happy to do that.
And it's just a sad state of affairs.
But that was my take on the Rittenhouse situation.
Yeah, I mean, I think that's a solid take.
It was challenging to see
all of these misguided narratives on social media
that were mis-characterizing what was actually going on.
I mean, my understanding was that
it's illegal to buy that weapon in Wisconsin.
But it's legal to own it.
You just can't purchase it.
Hence open carry.
Hence the state line thing.
But he's from Kenosha, right?
This is his hometown.
Purportedly, he was defending a car dealership
or something like that.
I think if you, if you bought into a narrative
that was factually incorrect,
that he was out there to mow down
a bunch of black lives matter people
than to just hear the verdict
without really understanding kind of what was going on
led to that kind of uproar in the wake of the verdict.
But the truth is as a lawyer,
like the prosecution had a very difficult uphill job here.
They had to establish first guilt beyond a reasonable doubt
on the offense itself.
Plus they had to defeat the self-defense argument,
which means they had to disprove self-defense
beyond a reasonable doubt.
So that burden is very high and the facts of the case
were just not favorable to garnering a conviction on that.
But I think that the idea that two people are dead
and a third is injured and nobody committed a crime
is a difficult pill to swallow.
How could nobody have violated any laws
and this tragedy occurred.
And I also think it's hard to swallow
that he was found not guilty on a number of lesser charges,
like reckless endangerment, right?
Where the burden wasn't so high.
The jury just went in 100% on acquittal across the board.
But like you said,
none of this undermines the tragic nature of all of it.
And it is disheartening that there is this characterization
of Rittenhouse as this hero.
He's been offered an internship by Matt Gates,
things like that.
I mean, I think he is being used.
That's disturbing, real people are dead.
And there doesn't seem to be a regard
on the far wing of the right,
that that really matters.
Because we have a living vigilante
and that vigilante is useful in this political battle.
And that's really disheartening I find.
It's beyond disheartening.
It's disgusting.
He's a tool in all sense of the word.
And he's being used that way.
Someone will go away.
I think the friend who is, I think dated his sister
and then they became close and he's a little bit older.
His name is Dominic Black,
according to the Washington Post story, I read,
he bought the gun for Kyle because Kyle was too young
to buy it for himself.
I think he's gonna go away.
So it's just...
I mean, I think he'll have to do some time
because that gun was illegally purchased and given to him.
So, you know someone's gonna go away
and it probably won't be Kyle, which is odd.
And then there's the judge.
I mean, the judge, he also was kind of used
as a kind of a declaration from people on the left saying,
"See how unfair this whole thing is."
But then the legal scholars for the networks were saying,
"Actually, he hasn't been as unfair
as some of this narrative online on Twitter is saying."
But I did watch Roy Wood Junior's kind of thing
on Daily Show, where he is pretending to bailiff,
and he's going back and forth with this judge.
And if you watch that, which we should link to.
Yeah, I didn't wash that.
You mentioned that to me last night,
I forgot to watch it.
You see how the judge himself and how he displays himself.
It is as if like it's a casual moment for him on camera.
As if this isn't a tragic thing.
I was very offended by the judge's overall comportment.
This is a very American issue.
No other country would look at this and see these guns
and vigilantes and think that that's legal.
And this narrative, that guns make us all safer.
I think we can throw that out the window.
It's preposterous.
I mean, the fact that like...
What is he 17?
Yeah.
Could acquire one of these weapons
and walk around with it.
And if you're carrying an AR15 and you're walking
into a tempestuous situation,
because there's protesting.
On some level conscious or otherwise,
you're soliciting conflict,
Totally.
Something is gonna happen.
And just by dent of your presence,
you're making whatever is happening more dangerous.
And he was not advised appropriately
by whoever adults were in his life.
And maybe he did it without telling anybody
it's probably he did.
But the only thing I can think of
where there's some semblance of justice
that comes out of this, is I hope the victims, sue him,
sue his parents and take their houses.
Because he does deserve some sort of...
There needs to be some sort...
And we'll talk about this in a bit.
But there needs to be some sort of correction
and some sort of reconciliation.
And if you don't have that, then you have
this gaping wound that's just gonna fester.
But if you can have some sort of civil resolution,
it's not necessarily gonna appease everybody.
But somewhere where there is a price to pay,
then I think you have a chance at reconciliation.
And I think, obviously
they probably wouldn't lose their houses.
Some big wealthy donor would just pay the fee.
But I do think I do anticipate a civil case out of this.
Yeah, I think that's inevitable,
civil suits are inevitable.
You tell me the burden of proof is much lower, right.
It's a different burden, yeah.
It's different burden completely.
All right.
Do you have any thoughts on Ahmed Arbery
I mean, this one, a different way.
Different way.
I also wasn't surprised by this.
I mean, I predicted both things
in the comfort of my own home.
I didn't predict them online.
So I shouldn't...
Yeah, I predicted everything.
Okay, Nate Silver.
I predicted the last earthquake.
Now I thought that this was different all the way around.
The prosecution was incredible in this.
There was this concern because there was only
one black juror that this was gonna be
another one of these cases where the killers got off,
but that didn't turn out to be the case, which is great.
There's this temptation to celebrate these things.
It's another tragedy of a different sort.
This is someone who's a runner in the neighborhood.
We talked about this.
It was so unjust.
It was a modern day lynching.
The only acceptable thing would have been guilty.
But then when you realize that they are guilty
and they got convicted and the prosecution was fabulous
and all these things are true.
And they did have to take the case
out of the local district.
It did take months of protest to get this case into court,
to begin with.
There was this period of time where
maybe nobody would've paid for this crime.
So if you look at both of those things
while it's great that there was a conviction,
it didn't come in without the pressure.
And so what we have here, you look at both of them,
you have a criminal justice system that still
doesn't seem to work the way it's been imagined.
I mean, I don't know what else to add to that.
I think it was a different scenario
from the Rittenhouse situation.
You know, Aubrey was unarmed
and the facts lent themselves more favorably to the verdict
that we all bore witness to.
But I think it's a situation also
where we have these perpetrators who were emboldened
by this citizens arrest law.
Which ultimately becomes part of their defense,
but doesn't win the day
because they never declared it to Aubrey.
And there was no felony being perpetrated
in the midst of that.
Which of course basically allows you to make the argument
that in many ways, this can be characterized
as a modern day lynching.
But I think ultimately what I take away from this
is from both of these cases is this situation
that United States finds itself in
where we have these expansive open or concealed carry laws.
We have these protective self-defense laws,
and then we have these stand your ground law,
self-defense stand your ground laws
and citizens arrest laws.
All of those together can be weaponized
to create a very dangerous, toxic situation.
It's almost like one day maybe
people might storm the Capitol and try to effect
a presidential election.
That might happen.
(both laughing)
It's in a dystopian feature.
Yeah, God forbid something like that happens.
It's just, it's all horrible and sad.
It is.
I mean, what do you take out of this as a sliver
of some sort of hope or shining...
Some sort of shred of goodness.
Having a spotlight on these things,
creates a situation in which we're talking about it.
And those conversations are the only thing
that can ever lead to any of the kind of
legislative regulatory change
that I think we need.
But the flip side of that is that spotlight also serves
to further divide us and create this rift
between these two narratives of Rittenhouse
as vigilante hero, or an indictment
on the systemic racist nation that we all live in.
So how do we move forward from that productively?
Well, I think that's a good segue actually,
but I wanna say one thing about Rittenhouse.
I do not put Rittenhouse in the same batch
of the people that killed Ahmaud.
Yeah, of course.
Rittenhouse is a stunted-
He's a confused young man.
A confused young man.
It's horrible.
He did not seek to follow someone and kill them.
And he wasn't the instigator of the whole time.
He really wasn't.
No one carries the gun if they don't wanna use it.
So that's a different story,
but I don't put him in that same batch.
But in terms of the segue,
what we don't have here is...
What we end up having,
whenever we talk about these kinds of issues
is we have two sides that are dug in,
and we don't have this idea of the collective.
And especially on the side,
that is for gun rights and all that stuff.
They don't wanna give an inch.
No one wants to look at this thing
is we're all in this together, really?
There's this growing gulf
and people don't want
to think about how to move forward together.
They wanna think about how to move forward
in this other future, but it typically comes
at the expense of this other...
The expense of the opponent.
South Africa is getting ready to...
Just transferred Oscar Pistorius.
The blade runner, the guy who had no legs,
but was a remarkable sprinter anyway.
He was an Olympic.
And I think he was in...
Was he in the actual Olympic games?
I think he was.
Yeah, he was.
He was in the actual Olympic games.
But then he killed his model girlfriend.
Claimed that he thought people were breaking in
and she had barricaded herself in the bathroom
because of a break-in.
But it could be that he was beating on her
over the course of time.
And she was protecting herself from him.
He ends up shooting her claims that there was invaders.
It turns out that wasn't the truth.
And he gets sentenced to 15 years in prison,
which sounds light to people here in this country.
But in South Africa,
they have something called restorative justice.
And he's now eligible for parole
having served half that 15 year sentence.
But to get parole,
you have to have a sit-down with your victims
or the victim's family, if the victim is dead.
And so they moved him to a prison in the town
where his...
And I don't know why I'm spacing on the woman who he killed.
Let's get that real quick.
I don't remember her name.
We gotta get that.
But her parents, it was Vika.
Riva Steenkamp is her name.
And her parents live in this town
that he just got transferred to.
And apparently there's seasoned professionals
that bring these two parties together.
And it's a brutal multi-day multi-session therapy session.
Where you have to come to some sort of mutual understanding
and forgiveness is the goal.
And taking responsibility is the goal.
Talk about mutual support...
This idea that we're all in it together.
That's how it works.
And I know having covered some prison reform stuff
for Long Reads.
The person I was following in that story, Lori Dawson
is a big believer in restorative justice.
Would like to see restorative justice here in this country.
What is the inception of that in South Africa?
I think it comes from post-apartheid era
to try to get people who are out of prison
to empty the prisons.
Because there were so many political prisoners back there.
I would have to do more research,
but that's my understanding.
And is there data that this is effective?
The data that I'm aware of is more in that
the reason that 15 years seems light for a murder case to us
is because we put people away forever.
But the data that I'm aware of is
there is actually a limitation
to how long you put someone away
to what becomes of their life afterwards.
And 15 years gives someone a chance
to actually rehabilitate.
So it allows you to look at the person as though,
we wanna punish them forever
because he took someone away forever.
And I get it.
I understand that impulse.
I also grew up here.
Punitive is only one arm of justice and rehabilitation
is another important prong
that we don't really value or prioritize in our system.
No we don't.
And then you see it look,
when we talk about prison reform or criminal justice reform,
restorative justice is definitely very much a touchstone
with people who are really active in that community.
And typically because it's poor people,
it's people of color who go away for crimes they commit
maybe when they're 18, 19 20.
This is the typical thing.
And we'd like to some way for...
Some pathway towards rehabilitation
so that we have less suffering overall
around this one crime.
So we can create something productive out of it.
And there's plenty of people who have come out of prison
and create a productive lives,
but it's typically because they just resolve to do it.
And it's the exception, not the rule.
And so when you look at...
But then the shoe is on the other foot.
You have the George Floyd case,
you have this case of Amhaud Arbery.
And typically the people on the left
who would be more into criminal justice reform,
definitely wanna see their pine of...
They wanna taste the pint of blood.
And I get it.
But when it comes to things like restorative justice,
you have to believe in it for everybody.
It's really interesting and compelling to see South Africa
go this far with it.
And it's actually seems to work
because they wouldn't be continuing to do it if it didn't.
And it's interesting.
It is interesting.
To me personally,
it's very reminiscent of the Amy Biehl story.
I think I've told this story on the podcast before.
I can't remember.
So forgive me if you've already heard it.
But Amy was a friend of mine at Stanford.
She was on the diving team.
And she went on to become an anti-apartheid activist.
She got a Fulbright scholarship.
She went to South Africa to study and she ended up
getting murdered in 1993 by Cape town residents.
I think she was driving a friend home
to one of the townships
and she got pulled out of her car and stabbed.
I think she was stabbed in the head.
It was a horribly vicious, violent crime
that culminated in her death.
And in the wake of that,
four men were convicted of the crime.
But they were pardoned in 1998.
Only five years later
by the truth and reconciliation commission.
Under that rubric,
if your crime was politically motivated,
you could get this lighter sentence
or your sentence could be commandeered.
And they established that
it was a politically motivated crime,
which was very controversial.
And this was a big story in Cape town
and across South Africa at the time.
But what makes this story so compelling and interesting
is that Amy's parents supported the release of these men.
They had to testify about it.
It was like a big thing.
And then in 1994...
Can you imagine your daughter is murdered?
And then you go to the hearing or whatever and say,
"Yes, release these people."
Can you imagine?
I can't imagine it.
I also can't imagine the pain involved.
I mean, I think it must have something to do
with forgiveness and moving forward,
but it takes a lot of courage to get to that spot.
So, no, I can not imagine any of that.
But the legacy of this lives on.
I mean, in 1994, her parents created Amy Biehl Foundation
that was set up to empower township youth.
And two of the convicted murderers ended up working
for the foundation, which is unbelievable.
Amy was honored by Nelson Mandela.
And there's actually two schools like a high school
and some other school in New Mexico
that are now named after her.
It just shows that there was obviously some sort of
restorative justice element at play.
Yeah, that's why I bring it up.
Because I don't know,
the truth and reconciliation commission
obviously comes out of the apartheid era as well,
but it seems sort of a close cousin
to this idea of restorative justice
in a different form.
The restorative justice belongs...
You'd think belongs to the future
of some enlightened society
when we're all able to let go of pain easier
and stop pointing fingers because it does come from...
The punitive side comes from the shame, shame,
we will stone you.
It's very old school.
Right.
Moving forward requires forgiveness.
And it requires a belief in rehabilitation.
And these other things.
It requires a very evolved point of view.
And I'm not saying I would be the guy rooting for that
if something terrible happened to people I love.
So it's not that I'm saying it's an easy thing.
I just point out that it seems remarkable to me.
And then the real takeaway
is that our sentences probably are too...
I mean, I think we know they are too harsh.
Cause we already...
We see it all over the states now.
There's been stories about DA's
that have been trying to empty the prisons
and empty the jails.
And that seems to be backfiring
with theft and murders going up.
So we're in this messy in between time
where vigilantism is up, crime is up.
Prosecutors (indistinct) abolish the police.
We're in this weird tectonic plate shifting time.
It's weird.
Yeah, where do we land?
I don't know.
I don't know, but we need more Bryan Stevenson's out there.
We do.
Talking about this.
His books are insane.
I know, it's good.
All right, should we switch gears?
We're switching gears,
but I think what I've realized halfway through this,
this is (indistinct) touching on these stories,
this is legal corner.
Yeah, it is kind of.
This is referral legal corner.
I was not a criminal attorney though.
So my acumen around criminal procedures is let's say weak.
Okay, but this is not a criminal case that's coming up.
We have a new case.
That's kind of right in the RRP wheelhouse.
And I've came aware of this because of my friend,
Alice Driver's reporting.
She is a gifted freelance journalist.
Her stuff's on CNN.
Her stuff's been in Time, I believe.
She's starting to write for the New Yorker now.
She's got a book deal that's happened
and she's got that going.
She has written for Long Reads.
She's very gifted, very talented.
I met her years ago
and we've just stayed in contact big fan.
And she has been reporting on the COVID deaths
in the meat packing industry.
And she was kind of talking about this on social media
and made people aware of this lawsuit and kind of posted
the link to this landmark.
Looks like class action suit brought by workers alliances
for the Food Chain workers Alliances community,
Workers Alliance, different unions
against Tyson Foods, Tyson Fresh Meats,
Keystone Foods, JBS USA, and Pilgrim's Pride Corporation.
These are the main meat packing industry.
And this case is focused outside of Alice's home state,
which is Arkansas, which she's been focused on,
but I'll talk about this case.
And I'll talk a little bit about what she told me
is happening in Arkansas.
But so the premise of this case
is these meat production companies
have received over $150 million in federal funds.
Since the pandemic started.
This was part of the food insecurity, concern.
Processing workers are mostly people of color,
which we know often migrants they're typically
Southeast Asian and Latino now.
But there's certainly are some African-Americans as well.
And some white people there,
but the vast majority is POC.
And over 100 have died in these states
where this lawsuit, these lawsuits
are taken place.
Under the employment of Tyson.
Yes, under the appointment
of these various met packing companies
Meat production employees broadly just a 100
that worked for Tyson.
Tyson and these other companies that I mentioned.
So it's a handful.
While white managers have managed to remain healthy.
And that 100 we should say is based on official statistics
and Alice doubts those numbers.
And she's been working in Arkansas and she is...
She says in Arkansas,
they claim it's between 100 and 200 just in Arkansas alone.
And that's just Tyson.
But Tyson has such an influence there
that she doubts those official statistics.
And she actually does this by going
to these small town cemeteries
and counting the headstones of people with,
with Karen names.
Cause Karen State,
Burmese migrants a lot of them are there.
Thai names and finds that it's over 200.
But the idea is that when we focus just on Tyson,
Tyson has incentivized workers to come in during COVID,
by giving them $500 bonuses twice,
while the office staff worked remotely.
So the premise of this lawsuit
is your white office staff got to stay home.
Your white office staff didn't have to come to work.
The POC had to come in and you're taking money
from the federal government, POC had to come in.
And by June, 2020,
when the pandemic was still rolling at its peak,
they were brought back in and the pre pandemic policy
of workers being fired for missing shifts.
Even if they're sick was back implemented.
Now, when you're talking about migrant workers
who live in company housing
and their rent for the company housing
gets taken out of their paycheck.
Getting fired is a big fucking deal.
Cause you lose your housing.
You lose your housing.
So that's what's happening.
And so even if they've been exposed to COVID,
they were encouraged to come in.
In fact, they were told they had to come in.
Even if they had known exposure?
Known exposure, this is what this lawsuit alleges, right?
Meat processing plants is also another allegation
have been COVID hotspots from day one.
As of May 2020, 6 of the top 10 per capita
COVID infective counties
had a meat processing plant.
They had higher infection rates than New York city and LA
when they were the "Epicenters."
So these-
Higher per capita?
Per capita.
So in these small towns,
more people were getting COVID per capita than in New York
at the height of the first wave.
Like I said, Arkansas, 100, 200 people have died officially,
but Alice thinks it's well in excess of that.
Clarksville has counted 9,000 people,
300 Karen refugees live in company housing there
and work at Tyson.
She is now seeing Afghans come in.
Afghan refugees are being assigned to places in Arkansas.
She predicts that they will be working for Tyson.
And then there's the other side of it,
which is she's interviewed some of these people.
And if they're coming from Karen state,
which we just talked about,
they look at this and they're like,
"Well, it's worse at home, this is better."
And so that complicates a journalist narrative,
which wants to paint the evil picture.
But that doesn't mean they're not entitled
to the same protections as people here in this country.
Sure and that can be leveraged
like, oh, it was so much worse at home-
Right?
So who cares how bad it is here.
Like the company can take advance of that.
And why are these places hotspots?
Well, you're working in refrigerated areas.
You're working very close quarters.
There's no six feet separation.
Yes you might have a mask and a shield,
but that's not going to save you from these other problems
that are inherited...
That are part and parcel of this kind of work.
And then pan back and you see...
We're talking about chicken plants and these lawsuits.
I mean, chicken waste piles up, it ends up being flooded...
Going into our rivers and streams
and causing a whole host of environmental catastrophes.
I mean, this is talking about intersectional politics.
I mean, this is like the way the food system
has basically created this problem
that is so intersectional is remarkable.
Yeah, have you seen they're trying to kill us yet?
Not yet.
It confronts this very issue
particularly through the lens of industrial poultry farming
and how these farms are in these rural communities of color,
these underprivileged communities, poor communities,
and the toxic waste sludge like...
Basically the fecal matter,
like all of the waste that these
packed in chicken farms create.
They put them in these reservoirs, these pools,
and then they spray it all over the place.
And it goes into the air.
And in the movie, there's a scene where John visits
this woman who lives nearby one of these farms
and they go inside the house and they test,
they like swab inside the house.
And there's literally poultry fecal matter residue
all across the house
and people die of respiratory illnesses or die earlier.
Or you have all these health complications as a result.
And of course this waste finds its way
into our water system, into our creeks,
and ultimately our rivers.
And then into the Gulf of Mexico, you know?
Kills fish, kills reefs.
I covered this with pork and East North Carolina.
I've been into homes
where they've had to deal with pig shit
literally slapping the windows in their house.
Covering their houses and saturating
in East North Carolina.
And the thing is when you actually
pan back from that process, the chicken producers,
the pork producers,
the people actually farming the chickens,
raising the chickens, raising the pigs, they barely get by.
Yeah.
The money is these...
Is the big companies and the processing plants.
So they are profiting.
So that's why they're going after this.
And there is...
Alice tells me there'll be other states
where they're similar lawsuits are gonna happen
and it's all gonna start to unfold as we go forward.
She couldn't tell me where,
but there are going to be other lawsuits.
This is the first of a cascade.
So, this was just filed and who's-
It was filed a couple of months ago.
Who's the plaintiff?
Who's the-
The plaintiffs are the unions for these employees.
I see.
Yeah.
Interesting.
I wonder if ag-gag laws get in the way
or create a barrier when it comes to discovery?
That's a good question, you know what I mean?
I think we'll find out.
Just got filed and we'll see.
The problem with some of these class actions
is it never sees the light of day.
They ended up settling and the lawyers make some money.
And I hope that's not the case here.
But it's interesting how it all kind of comes around
where Karen state gets...
Has their villages burned out, people refuge.
They ended up...
The lucky ones get to come to United States
and this is the reward.
So Afghanistan has its issues.
People escape, the lucky ones get on the plane
and where are they gonna land?
They get plugged right into-
Yeah, this other system.
And it's just the way of the world right now.
And it's always has been I think with migrants.
And there's always been people who've gotten lucky
or have worked their off and gotten out of it.
Some of those people will go to these Tyson foods
and we'll work their way up and do very well.
And some people could end up statistics,
that's just the way it goes.
But it is the food system as we know it right now.
Yeah, well, speaking of the food system
as we know it right now.
We have another legal dispute that we're gonna get into.
Legal (indistinct).
And as much as I celebrate the innovation
and the advent of all of these
new plant-based food companies who are creating meat
and dairy analogs,
that that can supplant the Tysons of the world
and render them obsolete.
That's a good thing for everybody, right?
Right, right.
But some of these companies are now becoming the behemoths
that they're trying to supplant.
And they're not immune from behaving badly
from time to time.
And I think it's important
just from an objective point of view
as an ambassador of the plant-based movement
and somebody who wants to see a plant-based future
for all of us.
I think it's important for our environment,
for our health and for a number of reasons
that anybody who's listening to this or watching it
understands about where I'm coming from.
But we're in a situation right now where impossible,
Impossible Foods, the Impossible Burger,
most of you guys know about it.
I had the founder and CEO, Pat Brown on the podcast,
we had a nice conversation.
Well, Impossible is now a massive company.
They're valued at $7 billion.
I think they've raised 2 billion.
Their most recent raise was something like $500 million,
which is great because we have a huge
plant-based food company that's providing
an alternative to everybody's favorite cheeseburger.
So that's something to be celebrated,
at the same time it's important
to hold these companies accountable and in check.
And right now Impossible Foods has sued
another company called Impossible.
That is essentially a blog and a series
of sort of online content created by this guy, Joel Runyon,
who's an ultra runner, he's a blogger.
He does motivation stuff and talks about...
I think maybe he has a supplement line
and talks about like fitness gear and stuff like that.
He's been doing this for a long time like many, many years.
And he started his blog and his company back in...
I should pull up the article,
but I think it was like four years
before Impossible Foods even...
Maybe you can pull that up Adam.
Yeah, pulling that up.
Four years before Impossible Foods even existed.
And he filed a whole bunch of trademarks.
Yeah, 2010 is when he began it.
And he filed his paperwork and secured these trademarks,
created a logo and this brand that he's been building
ever since for the last 11 years.
And if you look at his logo, it does look relatively similar
in terms of type face or font to Impossible Foods.
Well, Impossible Foods is now suing him
for trademark infringement.
And they wanna obviate all of his trademarks.
They're seeking to cancel preexisting federal marks
that he established over a decade ago.
And Impossible Foods has hired
Wilson Sonsini for this which is...
Wilson Sonsini is like the biggest Silicon Valley law firm,
like all the tech companies.
And it takes a lot of money to defend against these suits.
And Joel's just a dude,
I think he lives in Austin or something like that.
So it's truly a David and Goliath situation and-
And Joel claims that he thinks that they're just basically
using that muscle to get him to give up.
Right, basically-
But they also want him to pay
their legal fees or something-
Right, yeah.
Crazy.
And he's the dude with a blog and a small brand,
who's been doing this before Impossible Foods even existed.
So it does appear to be a situation
in which he's being bullied to relinquish these trademarks
that he rightfully and legally secured a long time ago.
Now I haven't read the complaint, I don't know-
It got thrown out.
What Impossible Foods...
Well, there was an article on Bloomberg that I couldn't read
because I'm not subscribed to it,
but it said that it was tossed on jurisdictional grounds.
But I wasn't sure if that was the same case or not.
It seemed to be the case.
But Joel has not commented on it
as of the time of us recording this.
Okay.
So I'm not sure on the state
or the status of this dispute at this moment.
But I think irrespective of how this pans out,
it's just not a good look for Impossible Foods
to be suing the small guy over something like this.
Like, look I'll applaud the plant-based companies
when they're suing over labeling restrictions
that say they can't call their plant-based meat a burger,
or you can't call oat milk milk,
or in all of that I think it's bullshit.
And I'm glad when people like
Miyoko's Kitchen stand up and fight that.
But to be beating up on this guy
and bullying him out of his trademarks
when you're in a situation where you're trying to win
the hearts and minds of people,
because we're trying to blaze a better,
brighter future for all,
it doesn't seem to be a very politically wise move.
It comes off as an elitist asshole thing to do.
Right.
And you don't have to be an elitist asshole
just because you've got a good idea.
(Adam chuckles)
I know and it's like does this guy with his blog really...
Is he creating reasonable confusion
in the mind of the average consumer
that he might be the guy behind the Impossible Burger?
Nobody cares.
(Rich laughing)
But the bottom line is though
that like the reason they get away with this
and all these big companies do get away with it.
Joel sees himself as kind of an example
of this happens all the time.
He made a video on Twitter and a lot of people shared it.
So there's been some chatter online.
But nobody really cares like the average consumer
when he orders an Impossible Burger at such and such
(indistinct chatter)
He won't know and that's why Impossible Foods
is not making a statement about this or whatever.
They're just going to pursue their claim
and whatever happens happen.
Right.
And they got 500 million the other day,
so they have the money for it.
Yeah.
And Wilson Sonsini is billing them.
They are billing them.
(Adam chuckles)
Some lawyers are working hard right now on Sand Hill Road.
Yeah, some lawyers have Joel's face on a blackboard.
(Adam chuckles)
Poor Joel.
Poor Joel, man.
Joel seems like a nice guy.
He does.
Anyway.
I'm with you on this.
And I like Impossible Burgers.
I'm not eating that often anymore because they're not.
Good for you.
(indistinct chatter)
They don't agree with me.
More whole foods.
I mean, you know what I look to take
from these last couple of stories though,
is that when you're talking about-
You said we not gonna make this all about
legal disputes now.
No-
(indistinct chatter)
This is a food comment.
As much as I do like the flavor of an Impossible Burger,
it still is a processed kind of food
that comes from a centralized location.
It's still kind of a stepchild
of the food system as it exists.
And I think the healthy way to eat
is local farmer's markets
or local markets where you can know where the food...
It's astonishing to me
that blueberries from Oxnard and Santa Barbara
are more expensive than blueberries from Peru.
I mean, the idea that the way that people eat
the industrial food that's delivered
to your average grocery store and we just buy it,
it doesn't taste the way it's supposed to taste.
It's not as good for the environment.
It's not as good for you.
You really have to try to get local with your food
and that's the only way to eat.
And then you're not part of this.
Yeah, Impossible beyond all of these companies
are a pivot away from the ills of animal agriculture
and as such should be celebrated.
The fact that these are alternatives
that have found their way into fast food
and fast casual restaurants and grocery stores, et cetera,
all across the world is a step in the right direction.
But just so we're clear,
the Impossible Burger is made from a mono cropped,
series of ingredients that are GMO.
It's a processed food.
It's not...
Essentially it's not a health food, right?
No.
It's problematic in that regard.
It's not a perfect thing.
No.
So there's like anything
there's pluses and minuses with this but-
There's good people on both sides.
Yeah.
(Adam chuckles)
So next time you go into whatever restaurant
demand your locally harvest Impossible Burger.
Yeah, let's just have salad at Taco Bell,
but I try it every time.
You do.
Do you have any locally harvested blueberries?
Where are those-
Like drive-through?
Where's that tube of avocado paste coming from?
Right, you'll be met with a blank stare for that.
I wanna shout out my buddy Toby Morse,
friend of the pod, friend in real life,
one of the most positive, optimistic,
cool people you're ever gonna meet.
Punk rocker behind the band H2O.
Just a great guy.
And he wrote this children's book
called One Life One Chance.
I'll hold it up for the camera.
Which is just such a cool self-created thing that he made
that he's self publishing.
And it's just a cool book for kids.
So if you're looking for kind of a groovy gift
for the holidays for a young person
or for a parent to read to a young person,
I would recommend picking this up.
It's got a foreword...
Well, first of all, I made a little cameo
in there can you see?
Oh, really.
Can you pick me out in the lineup?
I believe I can.
Yeah, on the upper left-
Top left.
Made a little cameo.
But it's got this beautiful foreword bud
by our favorite Instagrammer
and action hero Josh Brolin.
The bard of Instagram.
I know.
which is such a cool thing that Josh would write
this foreword for a children's book.
And it's so heartfelt and just lovely.
Josh seems the opposite of a client of Wilson Sonsini.
(Rich laughing)
He does, doesn't he?
(Adam and Rich laughing)
This poet, this (indistinct) layer are stuck
in the body of an action hero.
That is Josh Brolin.
Yes, you sent me his shout out
to Jimmy Chin's new book, There and Back.
And obviously we're both huge fans of Jimmy's.
Sure.
And that was pretty moving, pretty cool.
Yeah, Josh published
just a handheld talking to his phone video
of him expressing how touched he was by Jimmy's book
and he's paging through it.
And he becomes progressively more emotional
as the video goes on
where he's literally welling up in tears,
talking about how it has inspired him
to try to inject more adventure into his life.
His remembrance of friends lost and things like that.
And it just...
I don't know, it touched me.
I thought it was really beautiful.
Yeah, his wife comes in like two thirds of the way in
and obviously she heard him talking to his phone again
and it has to heckle him.
I know that was funny wasn't it?
I loved it.
I wanna get the link for Toby's book
so I can shout it out but I didn't know that
I'm pulling it up right now.
I think it's...
Oh, it's h2omerch.com.
Okay.
Yeah, that's where you can find it.
One life One chance is the name of the book
by Toby Morris with foreword by Josh Brolin.
What else do we got?
I think we're heading into the movies.
Yeah, we're going to get it...
We're pivoting away from legal litigation
and we're getting into streaming.
Should we take a break?
Yeah, why don't we take a quick break
and we're gonna be back with some hot picks
for your holiday viewing.
Sorry to interrupt the flow
we'll be right back with more awesome.
But I wanna snag a moment to talk to you about
the importance of nutrition.
The thing is most people I know actually already know
how to eat better and aspire to incorporate whole plants.
More fruits, vegetables, seeds, beans,
and legumes into their daily routine.
Sadly, however, without the kitchen tools and support
very few end up sticking with it.
So because adopting a plant-based diet
transformed my life so profoundly.
And because I want everybody to experience
some version of what I've experienced,
we decided to tackle and solve this very common problem.
The solution we've devised I'm proud to say
is the Plantpower Meal Planner are affordable,
all-in-one digital platform that sets you up
for nutrition excellence by providing access
to thousands of highly customizable,
super delicious and easy to prepare plant-based recipes.
Everything integrates with automatic grocery delivery
and you get access to our amazing team of nutrition coaches,
seven days a week and many other features.
To learn more and to sign up,
visit meals.richroll.com.
And right now, for a limited time we're offering $10 off
in annual membership when you use the promo code,
RRHEALTH at checkout.
This is life-changing stuff people for just a $1.70 a week,
literally the price of a cup of coffee.
Again, that's meals.richroll.com,
promo code RRHEALTH for $10 off an annual membership.
All right, let's get back to the show.
All right, we're back.
We're gonna talk movies and streaming,
but Adam had a little bit of a revelation during the break.
Yes, Alice a Driver just messaged me
with national statistics as of October 27th,
for COVID cases in the meat packing industry.
There has been 60,000 nationwide COVID 19 cases
among employees of meat packing plants
and more than 250 deaths.
Those are the official statistics and that's nationwide.
So more than double that quote that we gave previously.
Right.
Interesting.
But she like I said,
she believes the deaths far exceed that number.
Yeah.
All right, movies.
Yep.
We haven't done this in awhile.
So much content has come and gone.
I know.
Since we last...
I could do like a movies and TV podcast every day.
I consume a tremendous amount of content-
You know.
But we're gonna have to restrict this to two projects.
I've been telling you you need a spin off.
A spinoff show-
You need spinoff-
Because everybody wants to hear
my movie and TV recommendations.
It doesn't stop Will Simmons.
That's true.
But he's owned that for a very long time.
And he started as a sports and as a movies guy.
Pop culture guy.
His movie acumen is impressive.
They're very impressive.
And he has an incredible memory.
Like he can remember the scenes and it's quite amazing.
My point is there's room for another (indistinct).
Well, we're gonna spend a few minutes today.
I will say before we get into the two projects
that we're gonna focus on,
that I could talk for three hours about Dune,
which I love and I've seen twice
in an IMAX theater Foundation-
You've seen it twice?
On Apple +.
Yeah, I've seen it twice.
Of course, I've seen it twice.
Of course, you've seen Dune twice?
I'm a huge sci-fi guy.
I watched Dune.
Dune is unbelievable,
but we're not gonna get sidetracked, Adam.
I do wanna shout out my boy, D Mac, Dan MacPherson.
Who has an incredible role in Foundation on Apple +,
which I really enjoyed.
It's a breakout performance-
Good for you.
And I really enjoyed not just watching Dan,
but that series as well.
Which is very inextricably linked to Dune.
They share a lot of DNA.
Succession of course.
I mean, there's nothing new or revolutionary
about being a big fan of Succession.
I'm obsessed with that show.
I saw Power of the Dog the other night,
which I thought was remarkable.
The acting performances are amazing so check that out.
Before we get into the first thing that
we're gonna focus on though.
Is there anything else top of mind
that you just saw recently
that you wanna at least just check a box and-
Sure, I watched King Richard.
Oh, you did?
I haven't seen it yet.
And when I watched the original trailer,
I mean, it looked...
I thought it looked a little corny
to be quite honest with you
You also had a...
I remember we talked about this weeks ago
and you were like, "Really, king Richard?
It's gonna be about the Williams sisters,
but it's about the dad."
Here's the thing about me.
I'm a cranky asshole sometimes.
You are a cynical and we're gonna...
Yeah, I'm gonna have to debate you
or throw you down to the mat here
when we get into the movie
we're gonna talk about a lot I think.
We're going to disagree.
But being that as it may,
I actually thoroughly enjoyed King Richard.
My problem was when you have the two greatest...
Two of the greatest,
including the greatest women's tennis player ever,
and then to tell their story and call it King Richard,
I thought was-
It is a little weird.
But this is actually the point.
The movie only goes to the point where Venus is 14
and she just first turns pro.
So it's everything before that.
And I'm guessing there was a carve out
in terms of life rights that allow...
That is going to allow for hopefully
like a Michael Jordan has 10 part series
about the Williams is because that has to come,
they fully deserve it.
And this though was extremely entertaining.
You learn a lot about how much they worked
and how much effort it took to get the girls
to be taken seriously by the tennis elites.
And then how many times they were...
Tried to be taken advantage of.
How many beatings Richard took both in Compton
and then before that.
Just a remarkable family, a remarkable American story
and some great, great, great performances,
not just from Will Smith but from the girls,
from everyone in the film who play or a scene...
The woman who plays or a scene in the film,
let's get her name, she's fabulous.
And just a really fun movie, so I've watch that.
And I've been watching a lot of Curb Your Enthusiasm,
which is an epic season.
That's very character consistent.
Yes.
With the crankiness.
(Adam chuckles)
It is but this season is spectacular.
And to me like it...
Everyone loves Curb.
I love Curb even when it's a down season,
but the last couple of seasons,
it felt like an old guy trying to get it back.
Yeah.
They got it back.
I mean, this is a great season.
Seth Rogan's in it.
Vince Vaughn has a more prominent role.
It's really fun.
I watched the first episode of the new season,
but I fell off.
So I gotta get back into that.
But on King Richard, I mean, first of all,
Oscar bait completely, right?
Like this is gonna get a ton of nominations.
And although I haven't seen it yet,
my understanding is that it really buries this myth.
I mean, my recollection of that time
which is relatively vague,
cause I'm not a huge tennis person
was that Richard was sort of a
daddy Marinovich, like this hard driving,
really super aggressive
win at all costs kind of dad and he got painted that way.
So this movie really fleshes that out the real character
and the real human-
Yeah, he wasn't.
He saw those types of tenants dads
and he didn't like them.
And he wasn't that.
And the fact that you see all...
His whole thing was about avoiding burnout.
He didn't have them play a lot of juniors.
They played juniors for a little bit
and then he shut that down.
And that pissed off the coaches.
And no one want to...
You'll never get the sponsorships.
You never get X, you'll never get Y.
He proved all that to be bullshit.
He said no to the first several big dollar contracts
that were offered to Venus when she was 14.
And it wasn't just his decision.
He had Venus weighing in on it.
Just incredible what they've been able to do.
And he said it from the beginning,
they're gonna be to the two greatest of all time.
And Venus was the pioneer.
That was the first to go through the hell and paved the way.
And Serena came up behind her.
And you could also see how Serena...
Cause Venus got to play juniors
and Serena wasn't supposed to.
Venus got to go pro and Serena wasn't allowed to.
You could see that how that might've cultivated
within Serena this a world class fighter
was gonna take what she wanted.
And what an incredible athlete.
All right, well, I look forward to checking that out.
But we have to pivot our attention
to the greatest documentary ever made.
Okay.
The Beatles: Get Back.
Adam Skolnick?
Yes.
Your thoughts.
Well, I don't know why you think
we're gonna disagree about this.
I enjoy-
(indistinct chatter)
Yeah, yeah We have a little bit of
a difference of opinion,
which we can get into in a jocular way.
I mean, I'll just share like I was...
I'm halfway through part two,
but after watching part one the other night
I went into it, I saw the trailer,
but I tried to avoid reading anything about it.
Cause I wanted to go into it fresh.
I love the Beatles when people say, "Beatles or Stones?"
I don't understand the question.
To me there's no contest.
I'm not like a Beatles fanatic,
but to me the Beatles hold a very special place
in this encyclopedia of music.
I absolutely love them.
But I did go into the documentary
maybe with high expectations,
but also not knowing what to expect.
I wasn't even sure about the timeframe
or what it was that they were gonna focus on.
Other than that, there was all this found footage
and Peter Jackson was going to take it
and turn it into something.
And I found myself just absolutely riveted
by this documentary which for a lot of people
might be an acquired taste because it takes its time.
It's not, story-driven, it's a fly on the wall scenario
in which you're observing the band
trying to put together a variety of songs for a live show,
an album and a documentary.
And this is footage that was taken in the winter of 1969.
The month of January of 1969 chronicling this process
that at times can feel for the non-fan
to be painfully slow and laborious.
But I found it to be like the unearthing
of an historic document that belongs in the Smithsonian.
Because it chronicles the birth
of some of the greatest songs ever written.
And you see them as they emerge in the dynamic,
in the challenging dynamic
that the band is facing at the time
because they're on the precipice of breaking up.
Yeah, I agree with you.
It's like a fly on the wall in a room with geniuses
plus George and Ringo and-
See this is where-
I kid, I kid-
(indistinct chatter)
Jason is gonna come out here and strangle you.
I gave Jason a major Beatle fan, George and Ringo fan
editorial purview over your words.
So if you speak out of school,
it's getting cut from the podcast.
First of all, I love George and Ringo.
I especially love Ringo now cause like I-
Well, Ringo comes out really...
I think if you just sort of take
Twitter's temperature on this,
there's a lot of love for Ringo right now.
A friend of mine married...
A friend of mine, Brooke Fine married
the guitarist of...
Who was the lead guitars for Ben Harbor for years.
And he also played with Ringo
and raved about Ringo's musical acumen.
Watching this, I watched the full first episodes,
two and a half hours or 240 or something like that.
Right, the whole thing all three parts
is something like eight hours.
Eight and a half or something, eight yeah.
And I could see why.
Cause the thing is there's 40 plus hours of footage-
There's 56 hours.
These are 56 hours-
And then like over a 100 hours of audio.
So if I'm Peter Jackson,
I wanna give the most I can and I think he's done it.
He has such a light touch.
You don't see him in it, but it's so artfully edited
that he's obviously done such a great work.
And so anyway, Ringo.
I love Ringo in this.
I think he's there, he's working hard.
He's. basically attached himself to Paul's hip,
but he's also like always present.
Shows up on time, never-
Very puncture.
Never a negative word comes out of his mouth.
If Paul is in studio, Ringo in studio.
But Ringo because he's not writing the songs
and because he's the drummer,
he has to sort of sit quietly,
while this songwriting dynamic is playing out and-
Yeah, he surfs it.
And I watched part one with my boys, Trapper and Tyler,
and Trapper is a drummer.
And Trapper was like,
"Never have I ever seen an on-screen persona
that I more heavily identified with than Ringo."
Cause I've been present for...
I don't know how many hundreds of hours watching the boys
rehearse with their cousin and different band members.
And Trapper being the drummer.
I mean, there were lots of times
where he's just sitting at his drum kit like reading a book
or looking at his phone while everybody's arguing.
(indistinct chatter)
And that's exactly kind of the Ringo vibe.
Like he's just chilling at the kit,
ready to go whenever they figure out what they wanna do.
Yeah, Ringo is the tweener that's wondering
when mom and dad will stop yelling at each other.
(Rich laughing)
You know what was cool though to see?
I love seeing Ringo at the piano.
I love seeing John on bass.
And he could see Paul tell Ringo what riff he wants
and talk to George about the mechanics
of what he was looking for for a particular song.
I think it's Get Back or one of the songs.
And to be able to see Paul just rock in his chair
and actually create Get Back in such a riveting way.
You thought Ringo looked bored.
I thought Ringo got it and was hooked.
Like I felt him getting it,
whereas George seemed like he was yawning.
(indistinct chatter)
Yeah, I mean, I tweeted that.
There's one scene that's just unbelievable
where Paul is literally
creating Get Back (indistinct) whole cloth in real time.
Like you can see it percolating up in his consciousness
and playing it and you hear the kind of...
You see where it's going.
And there's George yawning.
And look, it's not a slight on George.
Like maybe they'd been there like eight hours
and he'd been doing that for three hours, who knows?
To me Ringo look bored too
but the idea that you're a fly on the wall
and you're seeing the inception of these phenomenal songs
just percolate up out of nothing is really miraculous.
The same thing happens with Let It Be.
Yeah.
Paul is like at the piano
and he starting to play let it...
He's working it out.
And everybody around him
is like talking about a bunch of bullshit.
They're like distract...
They're doing other stuff and you're like,
"Do you realize what's happening right now?"
How incredible that there were cameras rolling
at that very moment.
It seems like he starts with a melody
and maybe a hook in the vocals.
And then he builds the rest of it.
He is not worried about the words as much-
We have the lyrics,
like yeah they just come through a lot of the lyrics
and they kind of figure it out in a group setting.
Yeah, and then John-
And they're very cavalier about the lyrics at times too.
John is much more the words guy it seems to me.
Although then Paul edits him a little bit like,
"This is like too on the nose or too corny."
And that stuff to me,
to be able to see the creative process
of one of the greatest partnerships in all of creation,
certainly in all of, I guess,
Western popular culture to be able
to witness that is spectacular.
The reason that you're saying,
"And it's not for everybody."
Is that some people just wanna listen to the hits
and they don't really need to get into the minutia.
So for them, and that's certainly the case
of people I watched it with,
they thought it was a little bit too slow
and that it was a little too aimless.
And it was a little too, a little too-
I would sit through all 56 hours of it unedited.
Because I think it's such a rare and precious glimpse
into not only genius, but the creative process in general.
If you have any interest in how creativity operates,
especially in a group setting.
Whether you're a musician or a writer or a screenwriter
or a TV writer.
Anybody who's trying to birth something unique
and creative into the world.
And it has to do it with other people
to observe how some of the greatest songs ever crafted
came together with a group of people
who were having issues at the time.
And I think it also is a litmus test
regarding how attuned you are
to what those creative processes look like.
Have you had experience with them or not.
People who have not been in bands
or haven't been in TV writing rooms or things like that,
could observe what was happening with the band
and say, "Oh, you could tell, they're not getting along.
You could tell this band's about to break up.
This is all falling apart."
But if you've been in a band
or you have tried to collaborate on something creative.
I saw that and I thought they have a really...
Cause there's this narrative like,
"Oh, they all hated each other.
And they were breaking up and they couldn't communicate."
I saw very healthy communication.
They would disagree about things.
They didn't seem to hate each other.
They always treated each other with respect and grace.
They maintained their equanimity at all times.
There was always levity and comedy.
Like they're always cracking jokes.
They had their difficult moments.
And I don't wanna spoil that for people who haven't seen it
because things actually go down like shit hits the fan
and stuff like that.
But overall, I saw a group of people
who really love each other and were trying to do something.
Yeah, George did seem a little pissy.
I will say that.
Well, we'll let people watch it
and form their own opinion about that.
I know you have issues with George.
I always love.
(indistinct chatter)
What's the other one I love?
Listen, there's something very special
between Paul and John.
That made it very difficult for someone like George,
who is extremely gifted to have his voice being heard.
And that's gotta be really challenging.
And Paul and John, admit as much in the film.
And so that's kind of where things start
to go a little bit sideways.
But let's not forget how young these guys were.
All of them were young.
I mean, George was 26, I think.
And I think Paul and John were 28?
I think, John was 28 and Paul was 27.
27?
That's unbelievable.
Unbelievable.
That's unbelievable because, I would have thought,
even being a fan, "Oh, they broke...
If you said to me, "How old were they
when The Beatles broke up?"
I would've said, "I don't know 35."
No, no, I knew,
I knew that they were like 29 or something like that.
Amazing.
And I thought it was fun to see Yoko and Linda
and Ringo's wife who I'm spacing on her name.
Looking so good.
And then George's
Hare Krishna buddies looked great.
(Both laughing)
Sorry.
Yes, George brings in...
There's a couple Hare Krishna monks that sit in the corner
at what's the studio called again?
It has a very British name, like Wickenham
or something like that.
Twickenham.
And then Yoko who pulls up a chair
and kind of sits right with the group.
And what you notice over time is,
although there is something a little bit presumptuous
about her inserting herself right into the middle
of this dynamic.
She never says a word, she's not bothering anyone.
And it really upends that narrative that Yoko Ono
broke up the band.
It's hard to make that argument after you observed this.
I said that to a friend who has not seen this yet,
but who said the, Let it Be Documentary
is kind of the opposite of that.
And I didn't see the Let it Be Documentary.
Did you see that?
Or it makes it seem...
It kind of plays up the division's a bit more.
They are angry at each other that Yoko
is kind of getting in the way.
It doesn't seem that way in this particular setting.
In part two Paul kind of addresses it directly
and kind of puts those rumors to bed.
I mean, they acknowledge, "Oh, well, Yoko's here.
What does that mean?"
And they talk about it.
I think the bigger issue is that
when Brian Epstein passed away,
they didn't have like a team captain.
There was a power vacuum.
Explain who Brian Epstein was.
So he was like their manager from the get-go
and somebody that they...
You could tell in the movie,
how much they loved and trusted and respected this guy.
They call him Mr. Epstein.
He was their dad.
He put them in suits.
He told them what to dress.
How they would and they would do it.
And then when he's gone,
there's a power vacuum that I think I would intuit
that Paul fills.
When you watch this documentary, you realize
Paul's really the leader.
Nothing gets done without Paul.
He's the only one who has any interest in any organization
or productivity here.
Cause it's a bunch of artists and they think,
and do things differently.
And he's really trying hard in the best way
to try to drive this train forward and get something done.
But without Paul, nothing gets done.
That's clear.
But without Epstein,
I think it created this weird dynamic where Paul had to fill
a certain power vacuum,
but then that can lead to resentment
and all kinds of other things.
He would allow Paul to be Paul with someone else
(indistinct chatter)
George could have talked to Brian or John could.
Because you need Paul as the engine.
He's always gonna be the engine.
He is the conductor in a way.
But to see them all together and make their magic
and to have George come in with a fully realized song,
he wrote in an hour or at home the night before.
And then have Paul just invent them in front of your eyes.
Yeah, they're like, "I had this idea last night."
And then they sit down and it's 70% of the song is there
and they're working it out
and they're trying different things.
And because you know the song so well, you're like,
"No, no, don't do that, it's like this."
And how about the original words for don't let me down.
It was like on the road to (indistinct) or on the road...
Something like that.
That John was singing and playing.
And then he did one, he brought in a vinyl demo
of Across the Universe for them to listen to,
and then they all got into it.
I mean like, so the different approaches that they take,
like he actually did a whole demo
of Across the Universe for people.
And there's this other thing I wanna get out.
Cause I've read...
I did a little bit of reading on the show
before watching it.
And like you I stopped whenever a spoiler kind of came up.
But one thing that I noticed a theme of was Let it Be,
is considered this lesser album.
And partly because of Phil Spector, kind of doing some...
You know, desk fuckwit stuff with it later.
But in reality, there's five classics on this.
On this album, Across the Universe, Let it Be,
Get Back, Don't Let Me Down, and Two of Us,
which I think is great.
And then you have George, some of George's songs,
which are great.
And I mean to me, I love the album,
but it is considered a lesser album,
which I don't quite understand.
That's interesting.
Can we talk about Glen Johns.
Glen Johns.
What a superstar this guy is.
Wait Glen John's.
In the background-
The hammer?
No, not that guy.
(Adam laughing)
Glenn Johns was their
sound engineer/producer/silent Beetle member.
Who, first of all, always has the best outfit.
That guy is just rocking it.
Comes in with the scarf and the crazy sunglasses,
and a alligator skin jacket and the whole thing.
And is in charge of creating the sound for all of this.
There's one song, I can't remember
because I watched part one a couple of days ago
at this point.
Where they have a hurdle with one of the songs
they're working out.
And they keep going back and forth and it's not working.
And that was one of those situations where I was like,
"No, not that, not that."
And Glen says one thing and it solves the problem.
Yeah, right.
You remember that?
Yeah, I do remember that.
Then he's really kind of this unsung hero
and the whole thing behind the scenes.
Yeah, no, I do remember that.
And just an absolute legend.
Did he produce the record?
I don't know.
Jason, do you know.
Glen is just an absolute legend though, right?
Yeah.
Zeplin Stones, Who, Let it Be.
He comes up with the declining line.
On Let it Be right, exactly.
Sorry Jason.
(indistinct chatter)
Jason just gave me a dirty look.
Getting the stink eye?
From Jason, how dare you?
Jason, I love you.
The film comes out and Jason just basically sits
and watches the whole thing in one sitting
extensively, right?
Jason didn't get dressed that day.
He just sat there.
My head was exploding when I was watching part one.
I just couldn't believe what I was witnessing.
I was so grateful that this thing exists
and that we got to have...
Be able to witness this thing happening.
I just thought it's absolutely magical.
Like he said, maybe it's not for everyone,
but for me, I was like, just injected into my veins.
How did Peter Jackson get ahold of this stuff?
I don't know.
Yeah, I haven't read up on that, but I know
it's taken him quite a long time to get this thing together.
And there's been a team of people working on it
for a while.
Well he lives in middle earth.
It's hard to get the footage there.
Well the footage was sitting in a vault somewhere,
owned by Apple Corp.
And somehow he got permission.
They never used it for anything.
The intention was that there was gonna be this documentary.
That for whatever reason, they decided,
"Well, there's nothing here."
It's funny, cause in the thing they're like,
"How's the documentary going?"
And the director, who's a character in his own right.
With a cigar and the whole thing
he's like, I don't know...
He's like, "I don't think we have a documentary."
When things start going sideways.
And John's like, "What do you mean it's taking off?"
Now it's getting good.
It's pretty funny.
I want the guy that-
And it looks like yesterday.
I don't know how much cleaning up of the footage
had to be done.
But it literally looks like yesterday.
And the fact that they have...
There's like a boom mic
over to all these private conversations
that they were able to capture.
Yesterday.
I like the hammer swinger.
The hammer swinger who is a close talker as well.
No, he's become a meme on Twitter too.
Cause he's such a hero.
He gets to bang the hammer on the Advil.
So chime in on the song.
Jason, what's that guy's name?
That was their road manager.
The road manager, right, yeah.
He is a close talker, is he not?
Yeah.
He's great.
If you see the other footage of the Beatles
early 60s playing in DC.
(indistinct) is this the guy that comes out on stage
and spins Ringo's drum riser.
So the crowd on the other side...
Is one of the guys from the original.
That's cool.
And what's the director's name is?
Michael Lindsay Hogg.
Lindsey Hogg.
So he's the guy with the cigar and it's so funny,
Tyco YTD tweeted.
He's like, "This guy again, trying to get them to go
to Libya for the concert."
He's like, "They don't wanna do that."
Pretty funny.
I just love watching them in that room together.
How about when Linda comes in
and starts taking pictures and then you see the pictures
that she's taking.
Amazing.
It's unbelievable.
Soft focus, and-
I know.
I mean, I get emotional just thinking about it
and I'm like, "Why am I so emotional about this?"
But it's music history.
It's beautiful, it's okay to be emotional.
It is music history.
It really is a beautiful thing.
What else can we say?
About that?
About the movie.
I mean, I still have two episodes to go.
So I'm pretty stoked.
I'm looking forward to seeing what happens.
I saw the end of the first episode,
I was like, "Ooh."
I got to see Ringo's fat estate.
Ringo is a hero to many, I think.
Just his disposition throughout the whole thing
is so laudable.
It is.
Team player.
He's a team player.
And he's chill.
Here's the thing-
The others are pretending to be spiritual,
but Ringo is spiritual.
You've got your George issue and that blah, blah, blah.
I never did though.
But here's the thing, these guys are artists.
They don't function like...
It's like who cares, who showed up on time?
Ultimately all that matters is how great the album is.
Obviously-
Ringo cares, okay.
Obviously all of those personality peccadilloes
can either make the band grow closer together
or split them apart.
So it's not...
It is important.
But what you see is Paul being this guy
who shouldered the mantle
of being responsible for getting stuff done.
You have John who's consistently coming in late.
But in good spirits.
And it takes John a Long time to get warmed up.
But once he gets warmed up
and he gets in sync with Paul, magic happens.
And then you see them telling jokes and screwing around
and having fun.
And you think, "Well, that's not productive."
But that's important for the whole creative process.
You can't have one without the other
and artists, they're sensitive beings.
And they don't function.
Rationality isn't necessarily a priority.
I agree.
Look, I'm not saying it matters.
You don't have to be on time,
especially if you're John Lennon.
So here's the thing,
George didn't have to show up on time,
but he damn sure had to get there before John Lennon.
(Adam laughing)
And Ringo couldn't be last.
Ringo had to be first.
So yes, it doesn't matter, but it does matter.
There is still standing.
There is still the hierarchy.
John could be last.
Paul could've been last too.
But he would never be last cause he knows
someone has to be there first.
And if he gets there, he knows Ringo would get there.
So then there's waiting for two people.
I mean, that's just part of the workman like thing.
That's what you're seeing in this, which I like.
I'm not criticizing John for being late at all or George,
but I just think it is interesting.
George definitely was...
He was late, but he wasn't as late as John.
I got you.
Also, I appreciate all the little details.
Like the roadies who come in and give them tea.
There's always toast.
I love the tea and toast.
Toast and mermalade.
And the sound is for the documentary is Alan Parsons.
Amazing.
It's unbelievable.
All right.
Well, so watching that alongside this other doc
that you turned me on to.
Todd Haynes directed doc, the velvet under...
It's called Velvet Goldmine, is that right?
Yes.
No Velvet Goldmine was another movie that Todd Haynes did.
That was a narrative.
So this is Velvet Underground Doc.
It doesn't really have it...
I think it's just Velvet Underground.
Velvet Underground.
And it's kind of like a partner to this other thing.
Whereas Peter Jackson's got the invisible hand
doing incredible work.
Todd Haynes is definitely mixing it up.
You see his hand, but it's remarkable.
And he's using incredible filmmaking techniques
to create this hypnotic split screen tiled,
artistic vision that not only gets you into Lou Reed's mind
and John Cale and (indistinct) Morrison and Mo Tucker
and all the entire band Nico, but also the factory itself.
And Andy Warhol who managed the man.
And man, I want you to talk about this
and I've got some things to say,
but to see the two of them back to back,
it really set my mind and my brain into such a lovely swirl.
It really kind of got me thinking
about the nature of creativity in general.
Yeah, I mean these movies,
I think go very well together for that reason.
They're both time capsules about very romantic periods.
I mean, I have a irrational romantic attachment
with New York City during the period of Warhol's Factory.
And so this is right up my alley, this kind of movie.
But I think what's interesting about both of these movies
and in particular, the Velvet Underground movie
is that most rock documentaries are talking heads
reflecting upon the past.
Whereas both of these movies really immerse you
in a present moment.
They're, experiential.
You're with the Beatles when they're recording this album.
And similarly you're with the Velvet Underground,
because they have a lot of footage of them
in their Genesis phase.
So you're experiencing that band at its inception
and living with them as they try to kind of
put the pieces together and create something.
Of course there are some talking heads
in the Velvet Underground.
It's spice, it's not-
It doesn't form the architecture of the whole movie.
And the movie is crafted so that it feels
like an Andy Warhol experience.
And he uses much of Warhol's film.
Andy Warhol would put a camera on somebody's face
like Lou Reed and just let it roll for like an hour.
And Lou would just look into the camera blankly.
And he uses the split-screen in the movie
to use those clips, a lot of black and white.
So you feel like you're in downtown New York City
in the early 1970s.
And you can like taste the grit.
And you can feel the energy.
Because that was a period of time in which
there was this flourish
of interesting alternative creativity that was happening.
That was very special.
That birthed like so many amazing artists.
Not just in music, but in art and film theater, et cetera.
And I think that's why I have such an obsession
with this period of time.
And certainly the Velvet Underground occupies
a very special place in that kind of conversation.
Interesting, because I wasn't...
The context of Velvet Underground I had all off.
I thought they were early 70's.
I didn't realize they were like late 60's.
And this antidote to the kind of flower power.
They were the counter-culture within the counter-culture.
They were like a fuck you tot that.
They were the first punk band, I think you could say.
I mean, I would say it.
You would look at it and it's like the sound
on the dark side of the doors or like the drone and-
But it was more performance art than punk.
What was fascinating was learning about
how it all came together.
Which begins really with Kale and his Welsh upbringing
as this classical musician
who got intrigued with experimental music that was
going on in New York City.
Moves out there for the purpose, sole purpose really
of kind of spending time with these artists
who were really pushing the boundary of what even music was
just playing around with tone, right?
Yeah.
Just how long can we play this tone
and immerse ourselves in this sound?
Just really pushing the envelope
of what people would tolerate
and what that experience would look like.
The son of a coal miner.
Yeah, amazing story, this guy.
But also fascinating is that so many
of these important people end up
in the same apartment building at 56 Ludlow.
Which much like the Chelsea hotel
becomes this ground zero for all this incredible art
that comes out of it.
And it was that kind of proximity of these artists
and the free time that they had.
Cause I think it caused...
They all live there cause it costs like $25 a month.
So they didn't really have to work that much
to pay their bills.
And they could fuck around all day
experimenting with tone and sound and all of these things.
Get their $10,000.
Do these kinds of salons where,
all the hipsters would come together
and they would indulge themselves with whatever
artistic kind of thread that they were pulling at the time.
But the truth is it might not have gone anywhere
because they were playing this cafe
and that actually people hated it.
Except for one person who was in with the factory,
I forget her name.
And she sees it and tells Andy that they have to go there
and they need to see it.
And the next thing you know-
There was a cache to it,
even though mainstream people were hating it,
there was a core group of people who were the cool people
who are into it.
And the real inflection point was when...
And I think Kale says it in the documentary.
At some point during this tonal experiment,
somebody put an electric guitar pickup on it.
And then everything changed.
And then Lou Reed wasn't even part of it at the time,
there was this guy called Lou Reed
and he had a satchel full of songs and he enters it
after this tone experience is already kind of well underway.
And it comes to this-
Perfect.
Yeah, perfect storm that creates this whole new thing.
And then they add...
Then Andy Warhol becomes the manager
and then brings in Nico.
Which I didn't know anything about.
And insists, and fois Nico upon him.
And Nico's this glamazon gorgeous
Scandinavian who has this androgynous voice.
So it hits on so many Warhol levels,
the model type look with the androgyny and with this drone.
And obviously Lou is in that...
Lou came up when he was a teenager,
he was playing the gay clubs in New York City.
And like you said, they hated the hippies.
And so it's this very interesting mix.
And like I said to me, the two of these things together
kind of had me contemplating the nature of creativity,
which is not something I do very often.
But sometimes it comes up.
What is art?
What is music?
What is literary form?
What does any sort of scene or culture?
Isn't it just a collective dreaming
of what it means to be alive, to be human.
In all its ugliness and its beauty.
And now you have to...
This stuff has to hit for money to be made.
So he needed that dream together.
But that's not the primary driver and it's not
what brought John and Paul and George and Ringo together.
It's not what brings these people together.
It's not the underlying motivator of any scene.
Or any collective.
And to be a part of a scene, how cool is that?
That was always the dream coming up.
When I wanted to be a writer with my buddy Kelton Reed,
when we joined forces and we thought we loved the beats
and we love this era too.
And love reading Just Kids,
Patti Smith, being a part of that scene.
And you know, you are actually part of a scene.
You're like this early podcast.
I mean, this is its own type of scene.
It's more...
It's a little bit more removed because everyone's dislocated
in different places,
but you're very much on the forefront of this podcast scene.
And you're connected to some of these people
who are early innovators in the space.
Which is, I think another interesting art art form.
That's just starting to flourish.
And I was talking to not long ago,
the head of PR for audible about something else.
And she mentions neuroscience studies
about how part of the reason people love podcasts
and love audio books is when you listen,
versus when you read.
It hits a different part of your brain.
And it gets into the intimacy part.
Where that kind of lights up.
And so in it's way interacting as a different art form.
And the way people used to feel about music,
the way I felt about music or my favorite bands
and the merch we wore.
Is now shifting into the podcast and YouTube space
and people are getting merch for their favorite creators
in a whole different realm.
And this is the kind of stuff I was thinking about
while I was watching-
It's funny to...
I mean, yeah, I will take it as a compliment.
That's cool.
But my brain is thinking,
if this is a scene, I would trade this scene
to hang out with like Spalding Gray and David Byrne
and Lou Reed and Andy Warhol.
Or whatever was going on down there.
That just seems way more exciting and interesting.
And it's less sober, I think.
No, very much not a sober scene for sure.
Perilous probably would've killed me.
God spared me from being reared in that time and place.
You know what I'm saying right?
Yeah, I understand.
I mean, it's cool.
I do think...
And it's interesting because my sons are musicians
and I'm always thinking about the power of community.
Like what those scenes are.
You think of Grunge and you think of Seattle.
It's like what's going on in Nashville and country music.
And so I'm often like...
Or even LA at a period of time when like Beck was coming up.
There was kind of a scene at Spaceland and Silverlake
and all of that, but that doesn't really exist anymore.
Or Guns 'n Roses.
Sure.
The whole sunset strip metal era kind of thing.
So I always talk to them.
I'm like, "Tell me what is the scene like in LA?"
They're like, it's not really a scene.
There's a little bit of a scene.
I though that (indistinct) Bridgers has a scene.
Yeah, there's a little bit of that.
And they're kind of on the outer periphery
of that, I suppose.
But not like that scene where you feel like,
"Oh this is the place where this stuff like...
There's that palpable sense of something's happening here.
Because media is so siloed now.
And there's so much more of it.
So the saturation of so much content everywhere.
You can't possibly all be tuned into the same channel.
But back when the Beatles were coming up.
There weren't that many channels.
But if 56 Ludlow Street didn't exist,
does the Velvet Underground ever come to be?
No, but like Elizabeth Gilbert would say,
"Something else would."
The world didn't need Velvet Underground.
It's nice that it existed.
Something else would have been there.
And it'd been just as cool.
It just would have been different.
But now it's like there are so many more scenes.
And so then you have these kind of micro-climates
within that world.
In the context of the world.
Because everything's refracted and diffused.
There is no monoculture.
But these movements are always a contrast
to whatever the monoculture is.
No matter where culture exists,
the artists pendulum is swinging in the opposite direction.
And there is something to be said for proximity.
Now we have digital proximity that kind of resolves
a lot of that.
But, the idea that there are a bunch of artists
who are basically squatting in an apartment building
with nothing better to do than to collaborate all day long.
There is something unique about that.
Yeah right.
And the fact that cheap rent is a key to
kind of getting artists together is obviously well known.
That's what happened with Williamsburg
when Williams became a thing at the early 2000s
and plenty of bands came out of that era.
Seattle in the 90s.
Plenty of bands came out of that era.
You can't take real estate prices out of that realm there.
And so are rents, not real estate prices, but rent rates.
But it is interesting to think about.
And plus now it's more global, right?
We have access to Korean bands and African music.
And if you like drone music that you're hearing
in the Velvet Underground.
Check out the desert Tura guys that are coming
in Molly, and Algeria and listen to those guys.
Cause that's all blues meets drone.
Sure, and discovery is at your fingertips now.
Whereas it used to be difficult to find new stuff.
If you didn't have the cool older brother,
the guy to take you...
Or the guy at the record shop
who could tell you what was happening.
So it's right there for you.
So it's just a different era.
A couple of final thoughts on this documentary though.
I thought it was cool.
I didn't really realize that...
I mean you talk about Andy Warhol
kind of being in charge, right?
That had its pluses and minuses.
Without Warhol, does it ever get out of the gate?
And yet after a period of time,
they become stunted as a result of that relationship
and resentment around Nico and all of that kind of occurs.
That leads to ultimately the dismantling of the band
that never really saw the level of success
that I thought that it had.
It was interesting to hear,
they never really penetrated culture
in a way that I thought that they had that.
That comes much later.
And you know obviously Lou goes on
to this successful career outside of the Velvet Underground.
But what I thought was amazing was Sterling Morrison
goes and gets his PhD in English
and is a professor for a while.
And then he becomes a tugboat captain.
And then Mo the drummer is like an IT professional.
Can you imagine you're at your company?
And you have to go deal with the head of IT or whatever
and you realize she was the drummer in Velvet Underground.
But only the cool ones realized that.
Cause I bet a lot of people went in and out of that office
without even having any idea of who Mo Tucker was.
That's so amazing, that these lives
having full careers and lives
in the aftermath of being part of something
that was so culturally seismic.
Herman Melville became a customs officer after Moby Dick.
He did?
Yeah.
I didn't know that.
All right, let's do some listener questions.
Let's do it.
All right let's go to Al from DC.
Hello, Rich and Adam.
This is Al in DC, I'm calling with a question about
ramping up my endurance training.
I've been doing time restricted eating
and feeling great doing about an 18.6,
eating a lunch at about 02:00 o'clock
and stopping my caloric intake at about 08:00 o'clock.
But recently I've been ramping up on my running miles
training for 50K in the spring.
And I'm feeling like morning runs
doing 12 or 15 mile training runs
and going another four hours fasted.
After that run may not be optimal.
My gains and recovery.
I'm just curious if you have any insights
on how I should be adjusting my caloric intake
to optimize my gains during this training period.
Thank you for the question Al.
DC is a great running city, great place to train for 50K.
I think your instinct and your intuition is correct.
I appreciate the interest in self-experimentation
with restricted eating windows.
And I think it's fascinating,
the kind of science that's coming out around this
and the experimentation that so many athletes are doing.
My take on this with the caveat
that I think there's a lot of science that needs to be done
before we can get total clarity on this.
But as I see it now, my perspective is that
occasional fasted state workouts are okay.
And the science does support that there may be
a mild adaptation to that stress
that enhances aerobic state fat burning.
And I've experienced that myself
and I enjoy playing around with that.
But I think the emphasis has to be on occasional.
Because if you're training for a performance goal,
which you are doing right now,
the key I don't have to tell you to success is consistency.
Consistent training with an emphasis on
not only killing all your workouts,
but perhaps even more importantly,
optimizing your recovery between sessions.
And I think your current approach
of a persistent fasted state will not bode well with this.
You simply cannot perform day in and day out
with this fasting regimen,
without something going sideways at some point.
Or at a minimum failing to timely nourish yourself
is only gonna deplete you,
which you might be able to get through your workout
for the day and the next day.
But at some point it catches up to you
a couple of days later often.
And this is gonna impede your recovery.
It's gonna impair, potentially even depress
your immune system.
It may even lead to illness,
depriving your body of needed nutrients.
Which is only gonna undermine recovery
and thus the gains that you're seeking to achieve.
I don't think that I could be wrong,
but I don't think there's any elite athletes out there
who are trying to train in this manner
or who would entertain doing this.
You've gotta feed yourself.
You've gotta nourish yourself.
And as your training ramps up
and it becomes more and more...
Burdensome is the wrong word.
More and more onerous.
You're taxing your system in a way
that perhaps you haven't before,
if you wanna be able to bounce back
and do it the following day,
you're gonna have to feed those muscles and your body.
So again, fasted state, okay.
From time to time, occasionally.
I think it's good to stress the body
and establish physiologically,
and also psychologically that you're capable of going out
and doing a long run and not eating right away afterwards.
I think there's something to be said for that.
But not on a daily basis.
If you do wanna continue to play around with this,
I would suggest restricting
those fasted training days to maybe one at the most,
two days a week.
And to do it around your purely aerobic workouts
and to avoid it when you're doing tempo
or more anaerobic workouts.
So that's my two cents on that.
Again, I think what's going on here is interesting.
And like I said earlier, more science is needed
to figure this out.
Oh, "science".
You and your science.
I would fully agree with everything you just said.
Thank you, Adam.
I'm experimenting with a avocado toast diet right now.
Pre-workout or post.
Pre, during, post.
How long after your workout?
And there's zero fasting involved.
every hour it's more avocado toast for me.
When you're not eating,
I guess technically you're fasting.
You have like a 20 minute fasting window.
My biggest-
Your fastest state.
My biggest fasting window is on Roll On days.
We've gone a couple hours without you eating.
Are you okay?
Get me some avocado toast stat.
You're in your fat burning zone right now.
Great question, all right, cool.
Let's go to Kendall from Boulder, Colorado.
Hi guys, this is a Kendall
from Boulder, Colorado.
And my question and or point of discussion, I guess,
is the idea brought up in the conversation
with Reign and Riz
around the idea of the pursuit of happiness,
which is obviously an American thing.
And I think it's something I see show up on the pod a bit.
But I guess I ask, are we dismissing that aspect
of Life, Liberty and the pursuit of happiness?
Because we think that the idea is to achieve happiness.
Whereas it possibly could be that the forefathers
brought the idea of it being a pursuit
without the end ever being achieved.
To know that that was brought up
in a couple of different philosophers.
But I'm kind of curious what you guys think.
Do you think that the pursuit of happiness has an end,
or do you think that it was always meant to be a pursuit
and therefore the process along the way
is what creates the happiness.
Getting deep and philosophical with Kendall, from Boulder.
Deep and philosophical with the founding fathers?
I know.
Are we gonna be so bold as to try to read the minds
of the founding fathers Adam?
A lot of people are doing that lately.
(both laughing)
Not in this vein.
A lot of people are doing that currently.
Currently.
Across the spectrum.
On a lot of channels.
Did the founding fathers ever comment on this?
Has a legal scholar tried to interpolate what that means?
Whether their focus was on pursuit versus happiness?
Has anybody parsed that to your knowledge?
I don't know but I'm pretty sure
that George Washington was Brian Epstein
and Ben Franklin was John Lennon.
Why am I spacing on the most-
(indistinct chatter)
Thomas Jefferson.
Thomas Jefferson was Paul.
Yeah, very industrious and productive.
Who's George?
Who's Ringo?
John Quincy Adams.
(both laughing)
How do we layer that-
(indistinct chatter)
Maybe.
Yeah, that's an interesting question.
I mean, I can't read the minds of the founding fathers.
I have no idea what they were thinking about.
My interpretation though, is that
it's about the liberty of the pursuit.
So whether it's the pursuit of...
I don't know whether they ever expanded upon
how they define happiness or whether happiness
can only be found through the pursuit.
I'm not sure that they really thought that through
all that (indistinct), I don't know.
But for me, it's about the liberty to pursue.
And I don't think it's good practice
to be orienting your life around this aim of happiness.
I mean, happiness is a choice that we have in every moment.
We can choose to be happy.
We can choose to not be happy.
And in my opinion, the pursuit should be focused on meaning
and fulfillment and giving back service.
Things like that.
And I think happiness is a by-product of doing other things.
Not an end to be pursued in it of itself.
And personally, I mean, the things that make me happy
are really kind of a temporal states.
"Oh, I like jumping in the ocean.
You know, something of that...
That makes me happy.
But my life isn't in pursuit of jumping in the ocean.
It's a fleeting thing that I enjoy that gives me happiness.
But more broadly, the things that create
an extended sense of happiness in my life
are not the things that were kind of forced fed
in our culture.
Like luxury and convenience and what your bank account says
and all of that.
They're really the result of strain
or getting out of my comfort zone, tackling hard things.
Trying to find a way to give back, pushing my own limits.
And as an American, I'm very grateful
to have the Liberty to explore these things.
Which in turn ultimately lead to
a greater sense of happiness.
But I don't think about my life in the context
of happiness every day.
That's exactly how it works for me.
I don't think that's how it works for anybody.
I think that's what Kendall's getting at.
I think he wants you to speak to...
I mean, I think that he's kind of teeing it up in that way.
I think he agrees that it's about the pursuit
of some meaning or about the...
But I think you're also getting at what they're...
They're not trying to define pursuit or happiness.
So while I agree with you, and I think Kendall
is saying the same thing,
and that's why he wants us to speak to this.
The idea isn't to happiness as this goal,
but happiness can come in the pursuit.
I don't disagree with that.
But I think what they were getting at was more creating
the environment so that everyone felt the feel
like they can pursue whatever they want.
And so obviously they didn't...
That's the liberty...
That's the liberty piece.
But in their mind they created it
in their narrow construct of what they thought
was appropriate and good for the white male.
But that was that time, and that's what they did.
But I think if you look back they weren't...
They weren't actually creating that,
after they thought they were
or they tried to frame it that way.
But because when you look at studies.
If you're in a country where it's harder to get a loan,
you can't start a business.
If you look at Venezuela or Cuba or these places,
there's a lot of unhappiness because the structures
of that society, aren't allowing
for the pursuit of anything really.
And so I think the idea was let's create a place
where the crown is not getting in the way,
where taxes are low, where you can really just go out
and do what you...
And equitable access.
Right, equitable access,
which is the thing that we would like to expand.
Because obviously it was imperfect then, it's imperfect now.
But that idea of that democracy
is obviously something special
because it has been replicated in many places.
And so I think it was creating the conditions
to where we can have discussions like this
without having to be stressed out about
any sort of overlord or, you know-
Yeah, (indistinct) a mind reader.
I mean, pursuit of happiness in the context
of how they were contextualizing it or thinking about it,
I think meant or means like the freedom
to go do whatever the fuck you wanna do.
Basically without the crown getting involved.
Like you said, happiness being a catchphrase
for essentially like living the life of your choice.
Have we created that here?
I don't know.
And your idea that you don't pursue
this jumping in the ocean every day,
as the mother of a 15 month old.
It's something I pursue on a daily basis.
I don't get in there.
It takes a lot of pursuit.
And quite frankly-
But what is the half-life
of that feeling of happiness that you...
That is produced by that.
15 to 30 minutes.
So that's the thing.
It's not a lasting state.
It's not a fasted state.
That happiness is it?
No, that's why I moved on to the avocado toast.
All right, did we answer the question Kendall?
I think so.
Kendall could be the judge.
Kendall leave us another voicemail.
We're moving on now.
Let's go to Abby from Colorado.
Abby.
Hey Rich and Adam.
This is Abby from Colorado.
My question to you revolves around reconciling
two different topics that I know have come up
on the podcast from time to time.
And that are challenging for me to try and balance
in my life right now.
The first of these ideas is the need to be a people pleaser.
And the second is maintaining a service mindset.
No matter what obstacles in life someone is facing,
helping others is one thing that will always bring more joy
and fulfillment to anyone's life.
In my eyes the simplest and easiest way to serve others
is by being kind.
However, I'm also trying to become
less of a people pleaser by staying true to my values
and opinions and not bending them to fit the idea
of what other people want for me.
As an anagram type nine, which is the peacekeeper.
My natural tendency is to avoid conflict
and be liked by others.
Reinforcing my need to please people.
I pair that with the mission of serving others
through kindness and warmth, and I find it really hard
to be authentically myself while navigating day to day life.
So this is one long way of asking,
where do you draw the line between people pleasing
and serving others?
Well, Abby, in addition to that being
just an amazing question,
I feel the need to applaud you
for extraordinary self-awareness.
Yes, I thought it was a phenomenal question.
It's unbelievable.
I wish I don't know how old Abby is,
but that level of self-understanding I think is huge.
I agree.
And I love this anagram type nine.
I don't even know what that is,
but I remember getting really into Tarot
and astrology and-
You haven't done the anagram yet?
All right, this is your assignment before the next Roll On.
You gotta go do the anagram and come back
and we'll analyze it.
Okay.
All right.
I'll refresh mine, and see where I'm at.
We can hash it out.
All right, let's do it.
I think it's a really interesting question.
I relate to it a lot.
I understand that tension between people pleasing,
serving others and trying to establish
some kind of healthy boundary.
And I think unpacking that begins with first of all,
kind of a peek into your motivations.
Is your service this kindness or these other things
that you're doing on behalf of others?
Is it motivated by a desire to be liked
or is it motivated by the impact that it has on others?
And I guess then in turn your own sense of self.
Sort of getting clear on what your motivations are.
I think is important.
And perhaps even more elementary,
getting clear about your values.
What are your values?
So when you're acting in a way that feels like
it's not authentically you,
that's an indication that your behavior
is not aligned with your core values on some level.
So developing a practice of checking your decisions
against that value set
will help you calibrate your behavior
and your level of alignment.
So again, clarity about those values
if you have to write them out.
What are those core sets of values?
And when throughout the course of your day,
when you're people pleasing
and trying to be kind to people or whatever.
Where do you feel like those behaviors
come into conflict with your values.
I think is a good place or a good lens
through which to kind of deconstruct all of this.
If you're people pleasing out of a need
to maintain the peace,
but that ends up being contrary to your values
or violate some kind of personal boundary.
Then that's good information that you need
to realign your behavior to get it more consistent
with your value system.
So your value system value set,
dictates the boundary and protecting that boundary
at times, demands that you potentially place yourself
in conflict with others,
which then violates your peacekeeping disposition.
And that's where the discomfort comes in.
You don't wanna bum anyone out,
but you also wanna be true to yourself.
And I suspect that you're somebody who would rather
say the thing that makes people feel comfortable
rather than adhering to a boundary
or making sure that you're being true to your self.
And I think that's the growth opportunity,
like recognizing that.
And when those moments arise,
can you set a healthy boundary.
Do it graciously, so you're not upending
the piece unnecessarily,
but also respecting yourself.
And I think when you do that, as uncomfortable as it is,
there's a little kind of dollop of self-esteem.
A little kernel of self-esteem that you're planting
that allows you to start to get more comfortable
with who you are.
And I think you'll also find that,
look the peacekeeping thing,
the people pleasing thing that comes out of
a lack of self-esteem.
Oh if I don't tell them what they wanna hear,
then they're not gonna like me
and my opinion isn't valued or whatever.
But in truth, people respect you
when you demonstrate self-respect.
So by setting a healthy boundary and saying,
"I'm sorry, I know you want me to do that,
but I can't do that."
Or whatever the case may be, maybe uncomfortable.
And you're...
And every instinct inside your people pleasing body
will be saying, "Oh my God, they're gonna hate me now."
But ultimately they end up respecting you more.
And then you end up feeling better about who you are.
And then that muscle once flexed becomes easier to flex
the next time.
I love it.
Yeah, I mean, I'm a natural people pleaser
and wanna be kind and all of that too.
I find that there is a self motivation though,
to act in kindness and grace.
Because it means you just move through the world cleaner.
You don't have these hang ups of...
If you're creating conflict needlessly,
you carry that with you.
Sure.
It can be a drag.
Yeah, I get that.
I mean, I don't think there's any disagreement around that.
I think it's when that urge or disposition to people please.
Let's say you're around a bunch of people
that you have issues with, or that say things
that you don't agree with.
And you just kind of nod and go along to get along
because you don't wanna ruffle any feathers.
And then you leave and you feel like
you have a toxic residue around you
because you didn't stand up for yourself
or you didn't acquit yourself in a manner
that would be more consistent
with what you think is right and true.
Yeah, so it sounds like to me it's about when to...
Service is such an important thing.
And it's cool that she has that in mind.
And then not being a pushover is important
to be able to serve people.
Right.
Kindness is not antithetical to self-respect
and healthy boundaries.
You can still be kind and be strong.
So figuring out how to combine those two.
Michelle Obama seems kind and strong.
Yes.
How about Sylvia Earle or Jane Goodall
are both very kind people, but are very convicted
and very clear on what their values are
and strong in their opinions.
And don't suffer fools lightly.
But are very kind people.
And are amazing examples of service to humanity.
How about that for triumvirate of role models.
We landed it, we landed the plane.
Did we crash the plane?
I don't think we did.
No, there was turbulence.
That's a pretty smooth landing.
Yeah, well, we had to steer clear
of all your controversial ideas about George.
I know a lot of-
(indistinct chatter)
Hey dear listeners,
a lot of George fans in this building.
(Rich laughing)
Yes, there are.
John (indistinct).
No one wants to hear me sing.
Yeah, we do.
Let's get the Karaoke going.
It was a pleasure sharing space with you, Adam.
How do you feel?
I still have this blister right under my toenail.
You ever had one of those?
I like how you brought it all around,
like a good comedian.
Brought it back to the beginning, right?
But I'm not indulging you on that.
We're ending it.
All right.
You can find out I'm online at Adam Skolnick.
You can follow me at Rich Roll.
If you want to leave a question for us to consider
talking about on the podcast,
you can do that at 424-235-4626.
We will have copious show notes
on the episode page @richroll.com.
So check that.
Please, if you haven't done so already
subscribe to the show.
On YouTube, apple, Spotify, wherever you enjoy this program.
And that's it.
I wanna thank the team for putting together
an amazing episode.
I certainly do not do this alone.
Jason Camiolo, Beatles fan extraordinaire
with equally strong opinions about the Beatles
lurking in the shadows over there.
Credit that he is our Glenn Johns.
He did the audio engineering production, interstitial music,
all the behind scenes stuff.
Blake Curtis and Dan Drake are the...
What was the name of the Beatles director again?
What was his name?
Michael.
Michael Hogg?
Michael Hogg.
Michael Lindsay Hogg.
With two Gs.
(indistinct) Michael Lindsay Hoggs.
We have Daniel Solis on graphics, AJ for TikToks.
Davie and Grayson for portraits.
And George over copywriting, DK for advertiser relationships
and theme music as always by my own Paul Ringo.
and George Tyler Trapper and Harry.
Is this our last one?
Of the year?
The last Roll On of the year?
I don't know, is it?
I don't know, you tell me.
I think maybe we have one more.
We have one more.
I can't remember.
We might have to chamber a timeless one
before I take off for January or whatever.
That isn't wedded to the news cycle in any way.
Cause I think we might have to put one up when I'm gone,
so we'll figure that out.
But until then, appreciate all you guys.
Thank you for listening.
We don't take your attention for granted
and we'll be back when we're back
in some general vicinity of bi-weekly.
Whatever that means to you.
Final thoughts.
It's been a pleasure.
Always.
It's good to be back.
Thanks man.
We did it.
Good enough.
It's great.
Oka, bye.
Bye.
Bye Rich.
Bye gang.
Bye Adam.
(upbeat music)